foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
baby baby
baby baby baby
Ralph what's going on how y'all doing
feeling silly talk to me what's going on
in here my check my checks
okay okay
[Music]
I have some special guests
right quick
uh Derek what's up man what's going on
Cheryl Mack yo G what's up man what's
going on Christopher and
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all Dramatical I know it's
random but I'm addicted to flipping and
Snapple and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless messaging people on AIM check
my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all for
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard the boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with and I'm going places better
tell an Uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that yoga fire plane
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social but I'm still by Coastal I
got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
[Music]
I'ma just chill and watch them in these
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for attic
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to an
ebender I gotta be me though I know it's
my destiny work to carnido who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really be
civil you like to collect stuff
[Music]
[Music]
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
radio
[Music]
all right all right let's do a little
mic check soft a little mic check real
quick hello hello hello hello
hello good we doing good all right here
you hear you and we are live welcome to
the Island forecast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 282.
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's date
I'm very excited about our special
guests and we've got the valari gaming
pillow
check it out 10 years of Call of Duty
rejected by Sony are most hype games for
2023 and Ninja Gaiden plus Dead or Alive
reboots to discuss so we're gonna get
right into it
I want to introduce two Lords who are
not only great friends of the Realms of
IOP but whose passion for gaming proper
posture and joint health have now given
birth to the ultimate gaming weapon and
literally takes the pain out of the game
introducing the gaming entrepreneurs and
founders of the critically acclaimed
Volari gaming pillow the Lords of gaming
comfortability who's Eureka moment
transformed the common boppy into the
lordly Exotic we all use today
live from Beirut and Dubai and making
their debut into the realm of the Lords
mommy Lord hadah a lord Nadeem of the
valari.com how we doing sirs
respect here at the round table that we
talked earlier but I need you to tell
the people what have you been playing
what have both of you been playing
lately
did you be able to go first
so uh on Xbox I've been playing some
grounded I'm just telling you earlier
I've got a friend who's like really into
it he's doing all the hard work I just
pop on when I have a minute he's
building all the buildings yeah he's
building everything he's literally he
just waits for me to do the story and
then we go explore together with all
this like awesome armor that he gives me
nice so I've been nipping in and out I
don't need to watch YouTube videos or
any of that it's been it's been good fun
and otherwise I'm playing a lot of
civilization six as usual they just did
a new update
so yeah it's been good good I like those
kind of sieve six okay okay hello what
you what you been playing man yeah I've
been uh I've been hitting God of War
pretty hard boy since yeah about since
that game came out that's all I've been
playing all I've been playing before
that I was uh hitting plague's tale
really enjoyed that that was really good
nice
um uh next I'm probably gonna try
pantamid I'm quite interested to see
what that what that's going to be like
um looks like a very unique and
interesting game so I definitely want to
try that out yeah I highly highly
recommend it I get if you're a fan of
the time period And if you like kind of
like I would say like dialogue but um
RPG with choice and a murder mystery
yeah it really tremendous writing highly
recommend it man it's yeah it's really
cool why it really appeals to me is like
I grew up playing the point-and-click
adventure games like yeah Monkey Island
and King Quest and like
like those old school games that's what
I grew up on like
that's like that those are the like the
best games for me growing up so I think
it brings back that Vibe a bit so I
definitely want to try it out no doubt
yeah man absolutely I'm the same way a
kid remember king's quest and you know
what I'm saying oh yeah Monkey Island I
think it was my first PC getting lucky
yeah I love that stuff the mystery
figuring things out yeah exactly exactly
yeah they just uh re-released Monkey
Island inside Game Pass so I think that
was just like to get people warmed up
and ready for like pentiment like Hey
try this and then try a pentagon yeah a
lot of people a lot of people love those
styles of games and of course you know
we got the four well we're missing one
Horseman we don't know where he is but
everyone says some love out the attic
man I know he wasn't feeling well this
week you know he said he was gonna try
to give it a go but I'm assuming the
medication and whatever's going on you
know hopefully he's doing all right so
some love to the boy you know what I'm
saying but we still got the rest of the
Horseman here in the realm and of course
we have the most technical game like the
solo game all is for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Davis the Lord of clarity and Lord
patriarch of the iron bank my man Lord
Sovereign with a tremendous Villari
headrest exactly how do you use your
Volaris
rest of my neck right here
[Music]
I'm doing
yeah so unfortunately I'll have to get
out of here in a little bit
um nephew's 10th birthday party you know
this was planned I'm talking about oh no
oh I know I'm sorry
sorry I apologize nephew's 10th birthday
party and my sister kind of went crazy
and like like she rented out like the
pier or something some crazy thing like
that so Theo's gotta arrive because he's
got the Pokemon
has to arrive so um my apologies in
advance but yeah man otherwise doing
good it's just running around doing a
lot of family stuff the today family
stuff as well and but yeah doing good
all right generally played a little bit
of God of War
um it can't really say much about it
played some evil West
um enjoying it a lot it is it's still I
mean again that taste that we got of it
uh at PAX East still stands to me like
it's still it has a lot of like 360 like
dark insiders energy like uh you know
even the art style the movement the
simple overall Simplicity of it it's
just it's just a good time it's not you
know
trying to kill you with Laura and story
it's not that
um it's just a good fun action game and
and I think they hit out the park so
unfortunately I won't be able to talk
more about it but we'll talk more about
it next week um and then again what
other little time I've had what
vampire survives
it's a big one what is this game that
everyone is talking about it is it is uh
hello it is the simplest
simplest sort of dopamine hit game you
can ever if you looked up in a
dictionary and if a caveman walked out
of a cave today and said what is game
this this is game okay break it down
what is the what is the thing I don't
get it I haven't played it yet so what
is it I see them attacking my man or
Twitter
what they say yeah so what one word for
this crack
is all it is
like I said like I said when I talked
about it initially it really is just it
you you pick a character right and the
character starts out in a different
stage uh every time you basically start
off with one ability right this
character has uh whatever they throw uh
like a magic or they throw out like a
projectile or they have some sort of
defensive quality and as you kill
enemies all you're doing is running
around and trying to avoid these enemies
while killing as many as possible as you
kill the enemies they drop little uh XP
points that you're supposed to gather as
your XP goes up your level goes up every
time your level goes up they it unlocks
the ability to for you to unlock another
either projectile another Power another
defensive or offensive buff speed Buffs
things like that so as you continue to
try to avoid and kill these swarms you
keep getting stronger and stronger and
stronger and the storms keep getting
bigger and bigger and bigger so the
whole idea is to sort of survive this
and survive these vampires they call
them vampires but it's all kind of
monsters and just get stronger and
stronger and what happens is like if
you're good enough and you laugh long
enough you get so many abilities and
powers that you literally the screen is
exploding with AOE effects as you're
eliminating swarms and swarm it is such
it is it it is it feels so good to play
it is so rewarding to play and it is the
most simplest like it is like I said
it's game that is still down to what a
game is it is purest
exactly and it I mean again it goes back
to games like back in the day like
berserk uh even robots Okay Okay
Robotron Pac-Man just like stuff like
that yeah um
it kind of Harkens back to all of that
stuff in just the purest purest way the
music is amazing it looks like
Castlevania like old school Castlevania
uh yeah I finally I saw King posting up
but I said ah we got him we got him wait
till you get to my part bro it is it is
it is an amazing game it is it is an
absolute crime that it is not in the
game of the year category for the game
awards crime because it would beat
certain games no it would be it would
beat them it would beat them handling
it doesn't even make any sense yep oh
rudimentary the game looks but how
addicting it is yeah okay my God I mean
it goes back to yeah because attic
talked about
um Loop hero last year that Loop hero
kind of had that same thing but it's
more passive and it's just that that
that Hades feel that dead says feel just
that much simply on the
businessant he's playing it right now
while he's watching us you know what I'm
saying uh somebody Gary Barwick said
he's got a hundred and hundred
achievements already reach 111 bro yeah
they say it's great yeah people agree
they say it it is it is that thing it's
like when you finish one more one more
run let's go okay okay I'll give I'll
give myself a little down yeah that's it
that's it no doubt is it on Game Pass or
yes it is sure okay
gonna let you know
the the end of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the access
gay back
the profit of Xbox Swami oh he's not
feeling well I'm sick as hell yeah
okay okay my energy is in the bush I
mean I mean he's he's in the salt and
pepper Tower
[Laughter]
my wife was like oh so uh you just not
gonna do your bed I said no I'm saying
King of the statues there is nothing
less than that preview experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
ooh be love it Lord cake so glad that
you could make it today
listen I sat there and I contemplated a
lot of things are not showing up but we
got so many things for you guys today
and um there was no way in hell I was
going to miss our partners uh with their
glorious pillow especially with my son
telling me because my son didn't get a
chance to see the pillow right and
we were downstairs playing Vampire
Survivor I was playing Vampire Survivor
and he was like what's this and I was
like oh this is a vampire survivor he's
like it's in Game Pass I'll say yeah so
he takes my pillow he goes wow
this is nice I'm watching them
because it feels so good then he locks
himself in because he did the lock in he
did that yes oh it's perfect
this is the ultimate gaming pillow
I said I wanted to record him because
that's literally an infomercial yeah
so no all he wants is the pillow so he's
like well Daddy you know I said I know
yeah this is mine now it's mine
I told him you can't take mine because
his marketing purposes the but Daddy
will get you one
all right so let's go all this week um
monkey I got monkey into playing
fortnite with us so he joined the crew
and um we're we're playing fortnite and
then I said well let me download these
games I downloaded pentiment I
downloaded
um uh the Call of Duty because we
supposed to be playing with y'all guys
yes and I downloaded vampire Survivor I
said let me get some um God of War in
but vampire survivors popped up really
quick
check it out yeah let me check it out
dude
this was three o'clock in the afternoon
four o'clock in the morning
wow this was three o'clock in the
afternoon
four o'clock in the morning
I said no I could go upstairs and go to
bed
this game is probably singling because I
love roll lights right
the most addicting crack filled game
ever because they know how to hook you
yep
is like six seven stages some bonus
stages and each stage can be played in
hyper fast or with Alchemy or whatever
and they have like 20 different
characters that you unlock but you have
to pay for them right right
this is like Robotron the Natural
Evolution of Robotron classic classic
so as you go around the board and you're
killing stuff you're grabbing all these
points and this other this other things
that can help you buff up you know I
know solve went through that my
addiction is getting out the new
characters to see exactly what these
what their Buffs are yeah what can they
can do yeah because each character has a
different special that they shoot out
right some is rudimentary but then when
you get into some of the Obscure guys
like this um I got this a Bigfoot dude
who shoots out cherry bombs and then I
got this uh this witch that shoots out
cats
there's one girl who uh shoots out a
Mana spell
these spells when you hype them up and
you have to look at them because if you
pair them up with certain spells because
they're certain Buffs and then there's
certain weapons yeah
if you pair the the dispel up with the
weapon you can evolve it to its highest
form okay so you have to look and see
excuse me sorry you have to look and see
what is going to evolve your weapon so
what weapons you're good with like if
they have a natural innate weapon that
shoots up and down then you want a
weapon that's going to go out and
forward like um like the whip if you get
the blood whip all the way up maximize
it gives you health every time you kill
somebody so you're standing there
beating the brakes off of everybody
killing yourself and you're walking and
you have to get to certain spots and
this boss is in this game yes
um this this game has everything and I
know why it's not in um The Game of the
Year category because literally
there's no game that you can put up
there to say
it can beat this because you're not
going to play this game
what about that what about the graphical
Fidelity I don't care about that listen
I came from Atari 2600. yeah I I came
from
and it looks good yeah excuse me is that
old school Castlevania that's what it
looks like all right so
that level of Sprites on the screen is
supposed to cause slow down
it doesn't
this guy is a genius
he worked his his engine and and I don't
want to hear anybody saying that
this game is uh ugly he worked his
engine to the point that you could put
millions of characters on the screen so
without slow down gotcha and and he did
a really good job so excuse me sorry
again no doubt so you've been rocking it
I hear really good things about it
everybody that I know has played it is
even extremely that's game yeah so Kane
oh what's your favorite stage
the bonus stage with the bones okay
that you got to kill yeah I think so far
my favorite state is actually the second
stage the library because because it
reminds me of remember when I first
talked about the game and I was like
it's like a running back looking for
daylight yeah that stage feels like a
football field like an endless football
field but the one that you're going up
and you're going around right yeah
because if you don't have you don't have
a lot of you're running left and right
really you don't have a lot of space up
or down right so it's very narrow so it
really it made me feel like I was
playing Tech Mobile and like I had Barry
Sanders or or or or Bo Jackson you know
the Invincible characters in Tech Mobile
where it's just left and right did you
kill the Grim Reaper yes I did I killed
them too I killed them by luck I kind of
ran into him yeah and then but I at that
point I was like yeah that was just
explosions going off everywhere AOE
effects it was yeah man it is so
satisfying to play that game because
they understand numbers going up like if
the numbers go up people are happy and
if nothing but numbers yes it's like all
right so you have a hard stop you have
30 minutes on a board or 15 minutes on
the board
then they send out death
and Jeff everything on the board
disappears and death comes out and beats
the brakes off
that's it
if you're strong enough you can beat
Death and you get an achievement okay
okay say no more say less say less
definitely go check that out so it's
been pretty much that's been most of the
reasoning for you 400 some odd people
please hit that like button I'm sick as
hell I'm here you can hit that like
button he's like I made it I made it
please no question and of course we have
to give it to yourself to Shinobi Lord
Cognito spread that run into the realm
of iops I tell you what you ordered what
you need here shout out to my brother Mr
Maddie plays the Friday dude we had a
good one going up there talking game
awards talking news inter Max IPS also
have a freebie up there with the
legendary Josh Sawyer talking pentiment
you know interviewing him picking his
brain about the game check that out or
shout out to the last word or a little
Thanksgiving vacation this week we'll be
back next week and uh as far as me I've
been playing a lot man I was telling uh
how long and Nadine before we started um
I was obviously finished pentiment you
know what I'm saying great game finished
Somerville you know what I'm saying
great game there and uh definitely if
you're kind of inside and out of this
world those all this kind of atmospheric
storytelling games you might like that
I've been playing a ton of demio getting
ready for the new content coming up and
then still with grounded still with
grounded Still rocking and rolling with
grounded but yeah that's been it for me
so I'm going to get a couple of switches
what ending did you get with Somerville
okay so I don't want to spoil too much
but I love the ending and let's just say
the yeah because there's a I don't know
what's what there's a um thing you do as
a community yeah as a community that
can be very aggressive
and I did the aggressive action
and I it was okay but I will say to your
point again without spoiling too much I
do agree with you he is the worst father
ever oh yeah he's the worst father ever
again the story is about a husband wife
child and dog going through a very crazy
time with you know Invaders or something
happening some type of event happening
in the planet but yeah go go go check
that so you want to get the super
chances I got to take care of some other
business too cool I'll get these super
chats give me a moment
uh again my apologies for abandoning you
guys
we got God's hit man two dollar Super
Chat what do you think about Marvel snap
laying it down for the Lord here we go
everybody I haven't played it everybody
loves it and and we all picked it for
best mobile games
they got Raiden Blade Two Brown super
Chapman before one year [ __ ] play that
vampire game it's game of the generation
I will I was a lot of games out here man
generation
is right there that's what yeah yeah
XD Melo seven two dollar Super Chat
heard King got that 75-inch TCL for
Black Friday okay you pulled it off you
got that you got that door buster TCL
[Laughter]
I have to look that up my apologies
always nice to see the Lords on a
non-tcl 55 inch OLED wow wow they go
hard against these the other day uh who
got gaming for a team remember for 35
months oh bronze
Cog time to bend the knee to Jimmy G oh
homie got y'all looking like a Super
Bowl Contender yo you are you his Asian
like this bag goes silent for months for
weeks right it pops up when you have a
good game and throw four or five slags
and any other quarterback can do but I
go get a job I'm gonna let you have your
moment I know you feel good about your
man actually check your DM sir Forte I
miss you I haven't talked to you in a
long time check the deals brother but
anyway then we got to see and you see
you at 4 25 PM oh and as always hey King
boo-boo
then we got Mr Irishman remember for 16
months missed last week's IOP live but
it made a six hour tattoo session feel
like four hours shorter on Thursday
looking forward to today's messiness I'm
glad to provide you comfort to your
tattoo then we have a dead Planet Two
Dollars we chat thoughts on if XBox
holds back from TGA due to ABK I
certainly hope not I'm fed up with all
of this yeah yeah you're tired of it you
know but hey if I mean I I hope that I
would hope that doesn't affect I hope
not I mean I mean Sony has a whole hell
back so I don't see why I don't see why
either
Super Chat
there's ever a vampire survivors too I
hope it goes up to 16 big Graphics this
game is so addictive yeah I hope they do
like the messenger thing yeah
that'd be nice that'd be awesome okay
let me see if anything else dropped then
we got uh Carl Andrews Jr two dollar
Super Chat is Destiny 2 an improvement
from one yes
all right then we actually had one
before that car under Junior 2010 been
playing Destiny one has potential no
tutorial yeah they're very bad with
onwards you said you playing Destiny one
this is 2022 bro yeah I don't know
what's going on am I going back in time
like 10 years well he's one of those
dudes I'm not gonna play the new one new
one yeah yeah I gotta do it all the way
yeah I get it I get it if I gotta I
gotta plug my man it looks if you're
looking to get into Destiny you don't
know what to do because honestly
sometimes the onboard subscribe to my
man he bought this channel to cheetah
he's very good at explaining new players
and players who've missed and try to
come back anything that you've missed in
lapse in a very easy to understand stuff
so check out the bantus's channel yeah
and we have God's Hitman again two
dollar Super Chat I got a deal on the
series s for 200 oh absolutely very nice
no doubt no doubt we caught up with this
that's that black side we got a base 23b
can watch Super Chat thoughts on God of
War Ragnarok selling 5.1 million and
it's the 70 game just discussion over
now King I do not believe it so seven
point nothing
I'm gonna be a buck with you I don't
believe it
um but again it's [ __ ] probably probably
ship 7.5 million and it probably sit
inside the store waiting for these guys
to get their bucks together but I got it
ahead that's nice that's nice it's still
not Game of the Year
vampire Survivor come and slide up in
that DMS and be like bruh you looked at
Kratos and said boy here we go here we
go these are the last two salute the
Pokemon people showing the Pokemon oh
yeah Pokemon did what 10 million yeah
because Nintendo dudes buy stuff
there we go uh drunken ninja member for
27 months been a long year but grateful
for the community for being here
absolutely thank you blessings
absolutely then we have Lord Metroid
just doing a super chat before SOB
leaves bendy
and we should have some for the news
[Laughter]
yes sir all right no doubt I do have to
pay one more boost for the bill before
we start
um it's that time of the month really
quick man loads of gaming.net we gotta
salute the amazing tremendous writing
the talent that we do have here at the
website you know every month this is a
very competitive award and I want to
make sure that we extend acknowledgment
properly to the team and everybody that
is in the site definitely has a legit
chance of winning this award it is some
of the best so um it's time to celebrate
those specific scribe who went Above and
Beyond in the month of November he kind
of dominated the box office you don't
say as far as our movies and
entertainment section of the website
with Black Adam wakanda forever even
told us about the Gears of War Netflix
uh series coming so I proudly present
the winner of the Lord dizzy log net
scrap Vibe of the month to Lord David
yurion salute my brother so Louie did a
fantastic job now I know he couldn't
make it specifically to to get his award
but he did leave a little something for
us
hey everybody it's David yurian writer
for lordsofgaming.net just want to say
thank you for being subscribed of the
month I appreciate it it's been a long
time coming I've had a nice little break
for a while do some personal issues uh
she feels good to be appreciated you
might notice that my work is mostly
entertainment movies Comics stuff like
that do you write an occasional gaming
stuff but
I do appreciate it you guys have a great
day thank you
salute to the legend David you're young
taking that award again good to have you
on the site brother love the diversity
that you bring to the site and the
energy man makes us a better salute to
you and thank you for that and uh make
sure you hit solve up so you get your
reward yes sir and of course we do have
one more award that we want to give out
and again this is the uh Lord dizzy
editor of the of the of the month award
it's kind of respect the people who
nurture the talent who are the unsung
heroes behind the scene with editing
teaching doing a whole bunch for the
lifeblood of the site and this editor in
a short time has been extremely reliable
he's extra passionate when it comes to
Warframe triangle strategy you know I'm
saying for so now Persona 5 and uh we
definitely Pro and he actually has a
great um what you call a review out
right now Bayonetta you don't say review
right now check that out so we probably
present the winner of the Lord dizzy
lognet editor of the month award to my
man flame AKA Lord Joseph wrapped go
what's going on sir I see you in there
you like struggling with your bike
though
they're figuring things I can see he's
got the intense look but he I don't know
I would like to say thank you so much
because speaking for half a flame flaves
figure something out I'm gonna tell you
man uh sometimes I play Halo and I love
it and I love it too much and Bayonetta
three sucks
even though I cap about Warframe I'm
secretly a destiny fan
and I love Destiny I'm gonna take this
speech for him I love Destiny with all
my heart
is the greatest thing
thank you for this honor goodbye
oh he's trying to figure it out hold on
let me just tell him it's the moment
where what happens yeah I wonder if you
heard us I don't hear that I could tell
he had that because I'm slandering we
were always fight me he sees it back
yeah full flame yeah he's got some
technical difficulty don't worry about
it yeah unfortunately we got we got to
move on brother because I got some
patient guests but uh let me get this
last talk for y'all Kelly five dollars
of attack sold my PS5 Sony is finished
they ruined the last of us God of War
and Uncharted I don't know what to hold
on to for now for Hope but that is still
protocol everyone hey what's going on
with you man Kelly is the feeling that's
my guy um
he came over you know I spent a couple
of I sent a couple of goombs to him in
prison and uh he sees them oh yeah you
pressed him today
don't do that don't do that
let's put the crust in the chat for
Kings number third believer welcome to
the realm eggs number third
hopefully all flame can get it together
but I do gotta start but we all we all
set up for the um so
um
one second all right cool cool now we
got to what the Lord's been playing
gotta focus on our very patient didn't
hear me there we go all right cool I'm
sorry I can't hear anything through my
headphones I don't know why no okay okay
it's fine you didn't miss anything yeah
do me a favor will you play it back
you'll love it yes send them a chat we
got it we got a job before the call on
this one right now because we got we
running we definitely running late yeah
we got it we gotta we gotta get these
guys yeah because it's definitely I'm
sorry about that brother a little second
okay okay wait okay now please please
yes can you hear us
oh my God there we go all right cool yes
speech this is this this is embarrassing
I didn't even hear anything no you're
good bro
I'm just gonna pretend like I heard
everything that you guys were saying yes
anyways um
it's been an honor to write for its game
for over you know a year now and being
my parents Royal team and be inspired by
all of our amazing writers especially
David yes who is our Scrapper the mom
yes
um in fact the one article that I've
actually been proud of to make for like
the last couple months has been that my
Thanksgiving article where we literally
had everybody submit something
and neglect an article basically say
like you know uh games were personally
thankful for and everything like that
yes
David makes a lot of like those joint
articles and I would not have been
inspired to do that if it wasn't for him
so veteran veterans salute the Dave man
and it's salute you salute to you for
being reliable salute to you for the
consistency we really appreciate what
you do on the site and I make sure to
slander that you said that Destiny was
your favorite game Warfare it's trash I
want to make sure that the people knew
how you truly felt about Destiny and
spread the good word
[Laughter]
tremendous job man always a pleasant
worker you always bring a smile and
jokes brother enjoy your Sunday and
again thank you editor of the month
Joseph rapco flame y'all too I'm making
sure that I'm watching it
and likewise I'm gonna go back and
listen to that
but we do gotta run brother again that's
gonna be a fun one
um anyways I apologize to the great
Volare royalty for basically causing a
scene that was not my intention I don't
know what's going on you're good brother
you're good enjoy your Sunday have a
great day
and we are moving on so now we've been
very patient we got into the what the
Lord's been playing we paid the bills
logged in all that good stuff but we got
to switch our Focus to Lords Halal and
Lord the theme the video game system
history the journey into becoming
entrepreneurs and of course what led
them to reducing those physical pain
points for gamers by creating that
valari gaming pillow so let's start with
Lord first what are some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming
so for me it was PC so I grew up very
much a PC Gamer
um so yeah yeah it was all PC back in
there I didn't even have any of the the
really early consoles
um so yeah I was a PC guy a lot of
point-and-click adventure games like I
was saying before you know king's quest
Monkey Island
uh the Indiana Jones games you know
those were the sorts of games I love to
play
um and then as well like the strategy
games Command and Conquer was a big one
for me growing up and then kind of like
I fell out of gaming for a bit like a
couple of years and then I remember the
Sega Dreamcast came out and that kind of
brought me back into gaming a bit
um yeah I started getting into the
fighting games that are alive
um
and that was like and I remember it it
had like quite a short life cycle the
Sega Dreamcast but it was like a good
life cycle yes and then after that it
was
the OG Xbox oh that came out and that
that really brought me back into gaming
properly wait wait wait wait slow that
floor okay so for I gotta add that this
is surprisingly only for two one where
were you at the time where were you
living at the time when the Xbox came
out and why what was it about the OG
Xbox that you know really so I was
living in London at the time
um so I grew up in London
um and that's where I was at the time
and I'm not sure what it was about the
Xbox it was just something new and
different everyone had a PlayStation at
the time are you going against the grain
at that time
did it feel like the extension of that
Dreamcast that you just had like kind of
yeah yes exactly like it kind of felt
like a natural successor to the
Dreamcast
um and I don't know why I just I was
drawn to it more than the PlayStation at
the time and and man I remember just
Halo the first time oh I picked up a
controller and played Halo that just
like
honestly I was like wow this is like
this is gaming this is what a video game
is about right and especially like the
social elements of it I remember like we
used to get like back before Xbox Live
let's go back before internet gaming
let's go it was land gaming right so
I remember we used to get like two three
TV screens we used to get like two three
Xboxes hook them all up we used to have
an Xbox upstairs and Xbox downstairs
like 30 meter land cable who's running
the cables
yeah exactly exactly you you'd have like
eight ten of us in one house playing
um those are the days five those are the
days and like that was for me that was
like my rebirth into gaming like that
brought me back and then like
uh you know like all the Halo games for
me like unbelievable Halo one through
three I can't tell you how many hours I
plummeted into those games
um and you know and then in between you
know obviously there's
you know all like the the OG Xbox games
that like you know like the mass effects
all the lights of the Old Republic I'm a
big RPG Gamers so like
first person shooters and RPGs so like
for me a good nothing will be a good RPG
so like I remember when the first Mass
Effect came out that was like
mind-blowing to me
um you know I just recently replayed
when they remastered them I just
recently replayed all three nice back to
back nice that was nice that was a great
experience replaying those
um and yeah since then it's just kind of
like been
um
mostly Xbox uh you know I'll play the
big Sony exclusives when they come out
like the God of Wars
um the
the The Horizon forbidden West you know
all those games when they come out I'll
play them because they're great games
and I do love playing them but I'm you
know most of the other games I'll play
on Xbox you know I'm an Xbox guy so I'll
mostly play on Xbox especially now with
game pack game pass you just get so many
well there's so many games now like as
soon as I finish God of War I have like
a whole list of games I need to now I
need to add this vampire game as well to
that list yes I'm gonna be very very
busy absolutely not as tremendous but I
love I love hearing these histories and
stuff like I got to get the diva though
I gotta know his journey we're quickly
like what was some of the first gaming
systems or were you also PC and we got
you to give it sure no so for me I had
older brothers so it was the Commodore
64. when that first came out we just had
to put the tape in wait three minutes
for it to load which felt like eternity
and then a place I'm like I think it was
Rambo first Blood or something around
shooting yes and that was amazing but
then I finally got my own Sega Master
System oh going on I'm sorry sorry I
gotta talk to I gotta talk to say
goodbye sister royalty right now I'm
biased you are now my favorite thank you
thank you just passed the system I don't
get to hear this because I would talk
about it so yeah so this was a in London
uh late mid to late 80s uh Mass system
was was out and it was it was a
generation ahead of The Ataris and
everything else that was around you know
uh that's why I was a little bit before
my time I mean obviously I played it a
bit at my friend's houses and stuff but
when I had the muscles I just never
looked back it was eight bits and it was
like wow you know there's so many games
on it like from Sonic and everything
else that came out and then
like a CD uh all the way all the way
through until the switch happened later
down the line to PlayStation one okay um
but it was because Sega went down it
wasn't because I gave up on it right got
you yeah
yeah yeah yeah
I'm not unlike Cog who just defected
to the very end I appreciate that I
really try it
that PlayStation
he's real I like him
the Dreamcast like he said had an
untimely death no absolutely
um we know who the Cobras were
gonna get revenge
Philadelphia Tower power and they're
from there into you know what was the
app was it the PlayStation what was the
next progression after hold on did you
get a chance to make the giant um Tower
Power the the Mega Drive the mega CD the
32x yeah because you did it uh I don't
know about the 32x I had to make a CD at
one point and there was there was one
game that was really amazing on it and I
don't remember what it's called now but
I remember thinking a lot of time into
it yeah
maybe it was like this atmospheric
anyway not to not to dwell on that too
much but yeah like I played a lot of a
lot of my system and then I also kind of
flirted a lot with PC when it came to
command and Conquer Red Alert which I
was like I love that game like I'll
still play it today every now and then
just you know it's like a meditative
state for me just like repeat repeat the
way you were talking about from like 3
P.M to four in the morning that used to
happen to me with with red alert and
then I I play multiplayer against some
friends who'd then never play me again
because I beat them like so many times
in a row okay
um not to flex but I'm pretty bad at
most games but I was pretty good at that
one okay okay
and then and then after that yeah
Playstation One Virtual Fighter just
changed like the the game for me like it
was like the graphics seeing all this
game that you know we used to play so
many arcade games right uh you just go
to this place called Trocadero in London
like millions of arcades and spend all
our pocket money there yes and so
virtual Virtual Fighter was like
suddenly took that and made it 360
degree 3D graphics and he was like what
is happening here it wasn't like it was
just an evolution of gaming you know
absolutely and then never looked back
then you know got the we were playing a
lot of football games back then like uh
what we call what you call soccer you
know Pro Evolution Soccer way before the
FIFA
and uh back then it was like Allah was
saying it was all about the you know
people coming over sitting on the couch
next to you uh the side of gaming that's
disappeared a little bit now and uh then
we switched to the Xbox for Halo that
was Halal probably talked me into it
like did John I was gonna say like did
your friends our friends before like all
the videos are like yeah okay okay we've
been we've been friends since we were
um what 14 15 years old we've known each
other there like most of our it's nice
because most of our friends group are
like that like most of the people we
still communicate with and play with
online we've been playing with for like
now we've all we're all different
countries we've moved to different
countries and stuff but we still play
together online all the time and we have
a we have a group in WhatsApp called the
OG Destiny group oh let's go
talk about it and that's that's our uh
that's our group that we went from the
Halo Group to the destiny group
um and yeah we've been playing together
for like oh man
14 15. oh that's fine
it's crazy more the more you think about
it the older we get yeah
it's a bit depressing it's like 25 years
listen that's why I got OG Lords like us
too high low attack significance we're
seasoned we're
crystals
no I love the hair man this is so cool
just hearing the gaming stories and
stuff like that so obviously I want to
talk about you know one thing I respect
honest like the next step and you know
obviously we we love
this this product that you have the the
Volari but I want to talk about like the
the the Eureka moment so to speak right
where you know it kind of the origin
story of the Volaris so I don't know if
it's the devil Allah whoever wants to
start first like how did this happen
if you put it together
sure so uh much like you see me now it's
kind of sitting on the couch it was
during lockdown I was probably playing
Destiny because that's all I was playing
for a long time and I was always someone
who had like had a lot of I had back
issues the last few years and I always
like to be comfortable so when I sat
down I you know I'd put like one cup
push push up here one cushion there one
in the middle try and find a way to
basically be comfortable while that game
to avoid the kind of shoulder pain neck
pain Etc
um so I had my setup I was always
comfortable when I came it just took
about seven pillows to achieve it
you know so that meant that every time
I'd get up to get a glass of water go
use a toilet or whatever it would take
about an hour to take everything off and
put it back on and then I try and get
comfortable and then it's like a middle
of a raid yeah waiting for me yeah
exactly I was about to say it's very
annoying we're in the middle of a raid
and the devil would be like uh give me
give me a minute to go to the bathroom
guys and he'd be gone for like 15
minutes
I was just putting the cushions back
trying to get comfortable trying to get
comfortable so so that was the the first
situation and then my wife was pregnant
at the time and I saw this uh boppy
lying around on the couch right and it's
one of the kind of soft ones with um
like the bean bag filling in it uh but I
I like the idea that I could mold it to
the shape I wanted so I basically I put
it like the Villari as I put it from
here and I wrapped it around but it was
still on top of like the multiple
cushions it just replaced like two of
them maybe and it was like perfect
except that I still had like four
cushions underneath the boppy right
right sounds like well okay so this
shape gave me the idea basically and I
was like you know what I need instead of
all these pillars I need one pillow to
rule them all actually and that's when
the Villari was born like in my mind I
was like just a gaming pill a pillow for
this this shape that's thicker that can
absorb my upper body and my arms and
like just just let me be comfortable
while gaming basically and um and that
that was it that was the Eureka moment
that was the moment look man I'm glad
you said it because you know one thing
as Gamers like we we don't realize how
bad our posture is and how long we've
been gaming especially back to Destiny
like hello right how how those raids
you've been there three four hours
somebody keeps wiping you got to do the
whole thing over and you're in these
positions for so long it stops me from
hunching over yeah to lean forward
America right exactly it stops the gamer
League yeah you're so conscious and
straightening up your spine and if y'all
was noticing that's exactly what I was
doing when I'm sitting here you
straighten up your spine because you can
feel the tension on on your back so when
you straighten up your spine because you
don't have to lean over anymore you
don't have to put your hands on your
elbow your elbows on your um your legs
you can just relax and it gives you a
relaxed State I don't know you came up
with something that was mind-blowing
because it's absolutely a game changer
if you're sitting there for hours I was
playing Vampire survivors and I didn't
know how much time passed yeah and it's
the simplest thing because it's like
you're your propensity to lean comes
from the fact that when you get you just
start going forward and there's nothing
to stop your arms from going forward the
moment you hit that pillow though Boop
oh I'm right here and like there's no
need to move everything any further
forward and it's just like again
sometimes it's the simplest Solutions
and you just it's right in front of you
you don't even realize it no doubt yeah
I don't pretend to be like a rocket
science
you need to do a mathematical equation
yeah
it's not a cure for cancer or anything
but it was just a simple solution that
presented itself and I was shocked that
it didn't exist basically first thing I
did was try and buy one online right
yeah
okay where is the this idea I've had for
a pillow must exist and I looked it up
and I couldn't find it so I called Halal
up and I was like hello I've got this
idea
how that conversation go
and so yeah so I don't know Halal was
like okay sounds interesting but you
know I need to visualize it I think
you're struggling to visualize it so I
made a prototype and sent it to him like
uh a few days later and then hello you
can carry on what did you think yeah
yeah so basically when Nadeem first told
me about it I was like is this Nadeem
just being Nadine like Nadim can be a
bit like what is
Nadeem could be a bit precious at times
so I just thought to myself is this
Nadine being Nadine
um or does he actually have something
here because I also have the same issues
obviously we all do when we game
um it needs to be
you know you need to have a certain
level of uh Comfort when you game
otherwise it's like it's just not a very
enjoyable experience so
um you know he told me about it I was
like okay well let's see let's see what
the Prototype is like and once I got the
Prototype and I sat down with it I was
like oh okay now I get it like it's one
of those products when you hear about it
you're like yeah that could be good
right but once you try it you're like oh
wow no I this is this has really changed
the way I have to play there like now I
cannot play without it sometimes like
I'll say and I'll forget yes to put it
on and I'll be like
there's something there's something
wrong there's something missing yes oh
wait where's my Volare I'll pick it up
oh yeah there it is now I can play uh
and it's just completely changed the way
I game
um so yeah when he once like
I realized okay we have a product here
because my background is in startups
okay um so in London
um I was saying I grew up in London I
had a couple of startups and my
background was all in startups and I'm
operations so like I'm used to building
companies
um
so that's why Nadim came to me uh and
like once he came to me I was like okay
this is an idea we have something here
so let's do a bit of digging let's see
what's out in the market what is is the
most
comparable product out there and the
most comparable product out there is the
box it's a nursing pillow that is what
most people when they see our product
they're like oh it's a nursing pillow
and what's important to understand is
that while the shape is similar what
we've developed is quite a different
product so a nursing pillow is designed
for a baby for nursing a baby so they're
generally quite small they're quite thin
compared to our pillow and they don't
use the most premium materials because
they're designed to be spat on
essentially yeah
they sped along
the materials used are not of the
highest quality right because they don't
need to be right that's not the product
they're creating what we wanted was a
product that is very premium has a
really nice feel because frankly you're
going to be putting your arms on it yes
for hours on end you know I rest my arms
on this thing for hours and hours so we
wanted something that feels really
high-end and premium The Filling we use
is a lot thicker and more supportive
than what you would find in a nursing
pillow or a Boppy
um because obviously it needs to carry
the weight of full-grown human right and
some of us are on the heavier side I'm a
big boy I need this report exactly check
it out yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it
needs to be supportive and it needs to
be comfortable and it needs to give
the right amount of pushback right
because you want something that's
comfortable but also that pushes you
back so that you you are not you know
you don't have that gamer lead right if
it's too if it's too soft then you're
just gonna lean into it and it's not
really going to help much right
um so yeah so once we once we went
through the kind of prototyping phase
where we tested lots of different types
of materials and and fabrics and
fillings and this is where Nadeem shines
because this is where Nadeem being the
deem is a good thing let's go because
he's really picky right
every material is like no it's not good
enough no it's not soft enough no it's
not quite premium enough
yeah he's very exactly very particular
yeah I like things how I like things
yeah yeah he's muted right now but yeah
he's very particular
that's fine that's why I appreciate that
that's why we love it well I mean I mean
that's why we have such a great product
right because you know I'm I'm more the
operations and like the like
the math guy right so he'll come to me
and he'll be like oh we have to use this
fabric I'd be like yeah okay but this
fabric is like 30 a meter so yeah we
can't sell the pillow for three hundred
dollars did this let's go a little lower
please
[Laughter]
I mean I have some ideas guys that one
day I will make oh okay okay we get that
exclusive the ultimate pillow the
ultimate one VIP edition let's go
but honestly this one is it's it's a
collaboration and a compromise
everything's a compromise when you want
to mass manufacture something yes and
make it in a way that can sell and that
can people can afford to buy it you have
to compromise and that's where Halal and
I uh work very well together because we
you know I can like he was just saying
you know I'll say I want this and then
he'll say oh but that's too expensive so
it forces me to go and find something
that's almost as good but a lot cheaper
let's say right you know and then you
end up coming up with something that
that works very well that doesn't feel
like it's too much of a compromise
exactly
um and that does the job yeah it's the
most important thing also it had to look
good yes like for me like uh you know my
my wife's quite into interior design and
the idea of having something taking
space in our living room on our couch
being ugly you know like most popular
most like nursing pillows are really
ugly as well right
um so it was like no we need a we need a
removable cover that has to be washable
and it has to look beautiful basically
and so that's where all the different
designs come in no darshan is a is a
[Music]
he said Lord can you ask if they will
make more Halo pillows available they're
all sold out on the site
well actually yesterday we put a whole
bunch on uh of more Halo pillows they'll
be arriving in end of December by the
21st of December so nice yes and in the
meantime
why are you waiting little people you
get that IOP exclusive pillow right now
the cold cold floor 15 and uh get
yourself right now to pre-order wagon
exactly shout out to Miles honestly
honestly to this day with all the
designs we've done like the ILP one is
one of my favorites because you're you
guys the logo you have is just it's so
cool really excuse me thank you so much
just worked so well together I love it I
like the white little bumps
premium like I know this is Nadine right
here you know this is his work
right here
he was like it's just missing something
and you put little white bumps on it
yeah yeah really nice
it's ridiculous one of the choices we
had was whether we'd do like a screen
print or you know or like what kind of
printing we do for the designs and
everyone was telling us not to do
embroidery because it's like complicated
and expensive yeah but honestly when you
feel the difference between having an
embroidery that involves like thousands
of individual stitches versus like a
screen print like you do on a t-shirt
you know it's night and day you know
it's like a whole different tactile
experience when you touch it so yeah
that's what it's important to do that no
Shadow shout out to Miles don't PA in
the chat soft can we break protocol we
also did get a crazy Super Chat yeah you
know we did be respectful you know of
course uh so yeah you want your mommy to
read this please okay so we have
actually just got a couple I'll read
them quickly uh be Lou remember for 15
months y'all keep killing it King get
well soon I'd like to hear thoughts on
the continuous weight for Xbox
exclusives Xbox got myself and
personally getting tired I hear you
brother I'm not um listen I'm good I can
wait I got vampire Survivor
Thai casares three dollars Super Chat
Stoppers right vampire Survivor is a bad
addiction yes it's a good good addiction
flame five dollars Super Chat honestly I
think we can all blame the Xbox series s
for my audio problems couldn't be that I
didn't check it before joining no sir
have a great absolute salute the flave
wavy kosher remember for two months Lord
bronze shout out to IOP and King Nation
check out the LoveSac
slash XBox pillow chair I think it would
go great with the Volari also comes with
the series s and three months of Game
Pass okay okay okay
then we got Corey Tidwell with the 100
Super Chat thank you so much appreciate
that thank you happy holidays fellas I
really enjoy the podcast thank you thank
you so much so much it was really really
means a lot you know that all caught up
there yeah but no I hate I hear what
you're saying on that that balance and
and going for the highest end material
but at the same time the right price
point at the same time also you don't
want to go too low because you don't
want it to be like a Boppy and like you
said
the key for me is the like you said the
resistance coming back on it because if
you if you're resting your arms on this
for an extended period of time you need
that support and that's what it does and
I think it's it's pretty amazing in that
regard so you got this going on you got
this so like now where do you go down
after you how long you guys have talked
about you think you got something now
it's about you know Partnerships like
what what's the next step to get it out
well that's because I found you guys
through I think the kickstarter I think
yeah right exactly so I guess you know
from our point of view it was okay so we
have an idea we think it's a good idea
we have a product we like it we had done
at that point a couple of months of
prototyping and we had a product that we
felt reasonably confident with
um you know we said that first thing is
we did is we made like five or six of
them and we sent them to all our all the
guys in our OG nice
um destiny group basically yeah we're
like guys check it out let us know what
you think uh the feedback was good so
people were liking it we were like okay
let's give this a go so we were thinking
about what is the best way to get this
out in the market to kind of test it
without having to spend a lot of money
right because we didn't want to invest
too much money into it before we knew we
had a product Market fit before we knew
that it was not just you know a few of
us that wanted this and that there was
actually a market for this so that's
when we thought of Kickstarter so
basically for those people who don't
know Kickstarter allows you to
essentially what you're doing is
pre-ordering a product that doesn't
exist yet right so you're pre-ordering a
product that doesn't exist you're
allowing the creators of that product to
see that there's a market for it
essentially and then go out and
create the product so that's what we did
we we put it on Kickstarter we had a
very modest Target of like five thousand
dollars our internal Target so the team
and I wanted uh 20 to 30 000. that was
like okay if we get twenty to thirty
thousand dollars we feel like
we have a product that we should pursue
right
um and we had hundred thousand dollars
okay right so obviously we completely
smashed our own Target uh and you know
the the reaction was a lot more positive
than we were expecting we had a lot of
people outside of gaming who were
backing us uh you know people who were
just wanting the pillow to use for
um iPad use or mobile yeah you know for
sitting on their mobile
um funnily enough a lot of people who
were a lot of women who wanted to use it
for knitting really it's something that
never occurred to us if you think about
it when you're knitting your hands are
in the same position exactly as if you
were holding a controller right so or a
mobile phone so it's very similar so
again like
um we were like okay we have quite a
broad Market here and quite a range in
ages as well from from you know people
in their mid-20s all the way up to their
mid to late 40s so we were like okay we
definitely have a product here uh so you
know great we have a bit of money now
that we can go out and start producing
this thing so we went out we looked at
manufacturers in a few different
countries we looked at China we looked
at India we looked at a few different
countries
um and we ended up going with well first
we thought China but then with
everything that was happening in China
and the pandemic and them closing down
we were like maybe China is a bit too
risky it's just there's not a lot of
certainty there
um
so we decided to go with turkey for the
kickstarter production uh we went out
there we we commissioned a factory and
we got them to do the work for us uh at
the same time as all of this going on we
were approached by a company in Dubai uh
they're an Esports
um
they're an Esports company uh they own a
couple of Esports teams they own
um a couple of well they they like they
have a lot of influencers in the Middle
East and Southeast Asia side to them as
well they approached us and they saw our
project on Kickstarter and they were
very interested in making an investment
in us to help us grow the brands
so at that time it was that's still just
the demon eye but at that time it was
the demon eye and like a lot of work and
you know not a lot of support and how to
achieve our our goals you know we we
realized through the kickstarter that we
had more than just a small business here
we had potentially quite a big business
you know the gaming Market is huge huge
and
um you know it goes beyond just gaming
so you know we always had the idea that
we wanted to raise money but initially
it was like
we're gonna try this ourselves first and
then once we prove it and we're selling
and we're out there then we'll raise
money but when these guys came to us
they came to us with a lot of back so
yeah
yeah so they came to us with a lot of
support they could give us uh not just
uh you know from a financial point of
view they invested money but also uh
they have a lot of connections in the
influencer space so they can get us a
lot of
a lot of reach a lot of good content uh
you know they also
also because they own a lot of Esports
teams Esports is another area that we
definitely want to approach and as a as
a
Esports is blowing up right now uh
worldwide but especially in the U.S
starting to grow a lot more
um so Esports is a big angle for us and
they're huge in Esports so it just felt
like a really good deal for us to make
it took around
I don't know what was it now it's around
six months or something like that about
six months yeah yeah these things take
time but I mean it was all's well that
ends well yeah no luckily these are the
stories that you know Gamers need to
hear and again just the the steps when
you do have an idea the approach to take
and I love the mindset you know what I'm
saying at first was like okay it's just
such two let's see what we have here
let's gauge and stress right and then do
it kind of slowly and then when
obviously partnership came you sat down
and made the the one that you felt made
perfect sense for you guys and I love
the um the entrepreneurial Spirit of it
I think the question I have for you is
for um for gamers who have not
experienced Vlogs I got a lot of you a
lot of them now when I first saw I'm
like man that's just Bobby
we'll see you don't say that kind of
thing and then obviously trying the
product and I'm like no this is actually
something special so the question I have
to you is like for those who may be
skeptical on the fence
give me the pitch give me the cell
medium you want to go for her
okay well um I mean you don't know until
you try it
than you've ever been and you're missing
out until you do basically so
you don't have to buy it no you'll buy
it later when some other friends told
you you need it and more than that we're
so confident that we have uh money back
guarantee so if you get it and you don't
like it you can return it we'll take it
back no questions asked okay and you get
your money back but we're that confident
that once you try it there's no way
you're giving it back yo hold on hold on
akw is a fool he said I don't think you
guys should be allowed to enter that
market you have a monopoly we should get
the CMA to look into them
akw that was definitely fine
listen man it's an emerging market that
there's no one in the space and they
found something that is really people
really take it to it right now what they
do is they go and anybody that wants to
make competing pillows inside them
exactly buy them and shut them down
close them
honestly no it is something we've
thought about obviously and it's
something that you know if we keep
selling well first of the space it's
gonna it's gonna happen right we're
gonna have competitors but I mean that's
going to be a compliment the day that
happens because it means we're doing
something right right so you've got to
try not to get upset about these things
you know like uh it it is life if
someone wants to come along that they
they're they need to try and make them
nicer than ours which I think they're
going to struggle with you know yeah
they don't have a team
because I yeah they're gonna struggle
with the fact that all right so when my
hands is pressing down I got some heavy
hands
and I take it off the pillow bounces
right back yeah it doesn't lose form so
that was my thought process I thought it
was going to lose foam over a period of
time I gained with this pillow every day
of the week it hasn't lost form since
since I got yeah I haven't lost four
facts so I said wow um so listening to
you talk about how you know you use uh
premium stuff and then and the first
stuff that it was like bean bag stuff or
whatever
um it was a good choice in using the
materials that you have inside now the
materials that you have outside because
my wife loves it I can leave this pillow
anywhere and she's not taking deal take
that ugly thing out of here no no it
actually accentuates wherever it sits
right because life was a premium
situation so you made it pleasing to the
wife you made it comfortable to the
individual and I know this happens all
the time once the wife or the kids get a
chance to check it there's repeat buys
yeah they have to purchase another one
because the wife then stole the pillow
absolutely yeah yeah that's happened to
a few of our friends when we sent them
pillows they were like guys I'd love to
give you my feedback but I haven't been
able to try it because my wife took it
yeah and also pets pets seem to love
this thing so yeah if you go to our
website and you look at our reviews
almost every single one is with either a
cat or a dog
so it seems like you have to buy one for
your pet too I mean I have two huskies
and my Huskies got their own pillow
because they would not leave ours alone
I love it man love to see the success
love to see the growth in of course
we'll be remiss if all around but pretty
much already knows obviously we party
with you guys and we love support
department you know it's well I mean
honestly I couldn't have because I've
been listening to you guys wow for years
and for us like we were like who should
we send this pillow to and I was like
well I want to send it to the people I
really like I really value their opinion
because it was like for us it was like
sending it to you guys it was like we
didn't really expect or want anything
out of it it's just let's just send it
to the people in this space we really
like and really listen to and see if
they like it see if they get it so like
when when I messaged you I think it was
on Twitter Yeah you mentioned me on
Twitter yeah and I was like
um you know this is what we're doing do
you want one and those strings attached
just give it a go and let me know what
you think and when you answered I was
like go away
I was like I remember I told the team I
was Cognito
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah it was that was really like
exciting moment for us and when you
message us back and you're like I love
it
um and we started talking about okay
what can we do like how can we make it
more interesting and then we we you know
thought okay let's make you guys your
own pillow right
um and let's not just make it for you
guys but let's actually put it into
production and let your fans buy them
you know yes so like that's kind of like
what what it took took it a bit further
down the line and like what we're doing
now in our partnership is letting your
fans you know get a taste of the ILP
branding on on a pillow so they get the
best of both worlds you know the Volare
pillow and the your amazing ILP branding
because like the deem said I mean we've
come up with some cool designs but I
still think your design is like one of
the best
um and like it's really really amazing
design
um truly humble yeah well done with that
no appreciate it again you know I'm the
same type of person like kick those like
we we don't like to associate things
that we don't utilize or you know we
don't believe in and you know just to
see I remember when I got it I had that
I had my Eureka woman like no they have
something this is this is special this
is a quality product this is something
that hardcore Gamers will use if you
they try all they have to do is just try
it and if they give it a shot it's like
you said hello it's to the point now
when I if I make the mistake and pick
the controller back up and I don't have
it it's almost like a naked feeling you
almost feel like if something is missing
I I need to get back to what and then
I'm in my support my back is straight
arm's arrested and again for myself
personally you know I'm saying older
gamer I do suffer from rheumatoid
arthritis you know what I mean any
person with arthritic conditions because
being in these positions for a long time
even if you don't have arthritis or any
type of conditions those are very
painful and stressful on the joints and
the gamer lean that's what we do we Lean
Forward we're leaning into the screen
we're doing all these things that are
just completely anti-posture and the
last thing I say people don't uh talk
about is that you know a lot of these
arm rests and chairs right a very very
hard very rough well they're out of
alignment all right and chairs are out
of alignment so they raise your arms too
high so yeah stress on your joints
exactly good so and and actually I used
to get I used to get um
bruises on my forearm yes
I'm sitting on on gaming chairs
and I remember once it got so bad I
actually had to go to Physio for it wow
yeah
yeah yeah exactly it gave me a tennis
elbow basically yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely and again so yeah so now even
even when I sit in a in a proper gaming
chair I'll always have the pillow with
me well I love the fact that it is it's
it feels warm all right so a lot of
times you keep your warmth inside so you
said you're already cozy
you know you put your juice at the side
now I know somebody's gonna try to come
and make one with a juice holder and
you're gonna because the juice is gonna
spill all over the place
but uh this is definitely you know my
go-to pillow yeah for me what I like too
is solve it I'll let you talk I like to
put my photo on it so I got it I can
still give it I'm like okay that's what
the text video all right cool like it's
a multi I got a whole bunch of things on
it like it's kind of hilarious that for
me is like getting that perfect Comfort
like yeah I don't get that much time
again when I do like I'm on the couch
lean back all the way got the Volare
around the waist you got the I got the
the blanket over me like so I'm just
like I have my drinks on the coffee
table or whatever snacks I have or
whatever it is a moment for me so I
can't like again when I when we first
got this product I was like same as you
Kyle I was like oh man you know it looks
great but I just I don't know if it's
really gonna be the thing and then once
you have you're like oh because it is
that thing of like as a gamer you will
always lean forward you will always and
intense moments in the game no matter
what like if you're playing Vampire
survivors you're going to want to lean
forward at some point when things start
getting crazy you know God of War and
intense fight God of War fighting game
whatever
so it is just that thing that as soon as
my arms hit that the pillow it just oh
okay there's no need like there's no
need just relax you're still able to you
know game with the same intensity you
know it's just this natural inclination
you have to be like closer to the screen
or whatever but again as you get older
that closer to the screen does not do it
any good and not for the eyes either so
help me break our protocol real quick
shout out to uh Lord Galveston no doubt
10 ounce of a chance he just ordered a
second for Volari pillow one for me and
one for my son great show as always now
I just need an IOP Christmas ornament
make sure that's my kitchen I don't know
about the part of it brother but I'm
glad you got the valari for you and and
little man you know what I'm saying with
him a lot oh okay yeah Fortnight that's
my Fortnight oh absolutely you know
Sinister has left me in an alert oh okay
okay
I think one of our one of our members
joined us in progress
you know we finished up with a lot I did
wanted you to get give you up here
because I'm gonna be honest the deal was
not like
convincing addict it's a key thing yeah
any product like addict is the person
that if you don't convince I don't think
the product's gonna take over he
represents the younger generation and
he's a very particular individual I'm
gonna be around with you I was
definitely skeptical
most people are like let's go Cog was
like well you know uh you know I really
believe in their product I'm like look
man you believe it I believe in you and
what what I say originally I was going
to give the pillow to my girlfriend
because I was like I'm probably not
going to use it well she don't own it
it's mine so like what's funny is I use
it for like what it was made for and I
also use it as like a separating divider
when I'm sleeping with my girlfriend and
her daughter because it's like they
can't they can't roll over
I'm sleeping on this side
[Laughter]
yeah that's what I use it for I use it
to uh to
it's a defensive shoulders
look you see the creative usage right
now hello
whatever you want to use it for we're
happy
we gotta get going man I know we got we
gotta be a little bit real quick what
did you guys think about like when we
did our first promos and we all had like
the you know we were like all using our
valari in different ways did you guys
ever picture like somebody would do a
promo like that or even think about
using the using the pillow in a
different way than it was intended yeah
[Laughter]
it's great I mean that's the thing when
you put something out in the world you
have an idea for how how you use it when
it's for you know how you want it done
and then other people will do their own
thing with anyone else that's cool I
didn't think of that you know that works
so yeah I'm not here to tell people what
to do and not to do with their pillow
once they buy it it's up to them no no
we can do whatever they want absolutely
I love the product again absolute
pleasure to have you in the room we got
to actually find a question before we
get you guys out here we know the time
difference but uh I got to ask it's my
gaming perspective was the question we
asked all those in the room I need your
top five video games or franchises of
all time let's start with Lord hanau
first so he's he's a piece oh wow okay
let's go top five of all time yeah oh
wow in in any order or just a top five
any order and it could be a single game
or the franchise
okay okay that makes it a bit easier all
right so so definitely franchises Halo
Mass Effect those two are in there
um individual games uh I would say
Witcher 3 for me is loving you one of
the best games I've ever played
um I I absolutely love that game I was
so addicted to it I just couldn't get
enough of it
um I want to say cyberpunk because I I
had a similar feeling playing it but
just because of all the issues that it
had it kind of it took away from that so
I don't think I can quite put it in in
that top ten okay top five okay
um I'll also put Knights of the Old
Republic in there I think as you see
there these are mostly RPGs because why
you like Xbox
first person in RPG has got a covered
for you moving forward so how many are
we on now four one more four okay and
then my last one is gonna be Bioshock
these are quality hello
that that game was like again when it
came out it was so different but a
different and unique and it kind of like
had all those great RPG like had some
RPG elements but at the same time it was
just a really fun game
um so yeah that was great oh that's
awesome that's my uh that's my top five
Wrong five Lord the Deep you are up
hardcore gaming let's talk I mean it's
it's it's it's hard to follow without
repeating some of those
um so I actually Kotor actually played
only recently a year ago on my iPad
believe it or not I missed it when it
first came out okay but even playing it
like a year ago on the iPad with the
touch screen it's actually amazing with
that and that was we made it into one of
my old time top games I loved it but I
think in terms of franchise I'd have to
say Destiny is up there for me I've
played so many so many hours of my like
I've played that game more than any
other game what's your favorite rate
real quick what's your favorite I mean
the first ones were the best right so
the Vault of Glass was the best and you
know and then they got like at the last
I I missed two out of the last three I
must admit because we've stopped playing
it because it's not the kind of game you
can play on your own right at least not
not raiding yeah and our group has just
gotten so busy now with kids and
everything yeah it just doesn't doesn't
work
um destiny I think I'd have to put
Skyrim in there
something I sunk a lot of hours into I
really enjoyed the the RPG elements of
it yes
um and then Red Alert for me uh come on
and Conquer like that whole series
generals all of them all the way up
saying all of those I like that
and then I didn't know if does Halo make
it in there or not oh does it oh it's
all defense I don't know it's on the
pinup because only because like the
first few were amazing and then the last
few weren't great but then the last one
was good so I don't know okay maybe
maybe not I think maybe I'd have to go
uh civilization instead yes
attic is approving of your choice
civilization isn't really technically an
RTS it's like a turn-based game yeah
yeah it's turn based but it's amazing I
mean what's great about it is it's the
best game that's been optimized for the
iPad I've ever played I think it's
perfect on the iPad better than anything
else modern deep is very mobile yeah
yeah and I do most of my gaming exactly
I do most of my gaming on my iPad
because a lot of the time like if it's
during the day and you're working and
you just got like you want to do
something while you're waiting for a
call or something like that and you've
got a bit of time you just flip between
the apps right from your emails you flip
in civilizations open I can't like turn
on my Xbox and play
yeah
so that's four absolutely yeah oh is
that four well technically
no no yeah the first one
I'm sure I'm forgetting something I love
but oh SimCity I guess would happen
classic yeah
as as a standalone game yeah one of the
best I've played I think no doubt
definitely final question I don't know
if that's gone no no please no I'm sorry
no no sorry I don't know if that's five
or six or four but it's a lot of games
tremendous List brother I love I love
the diversity in the lineup and I gotta
ask the final question for both of you
uh Lord Hall I think I know the answer
to this but I'm still gonna ask favorite
console of all time and why
um
OG Xbox OG Xbox because it got me back
into gaming so I had you know I had done
a lot of gaming as a young teenager
um on PC but then I kind of like lost my
love for gaming a bit like the Sega
Dreamcast I played it a bit but mostly
just with with with friends yeah
um but I remember the OG Xbox it brought
me back to life when it comes to gaming
so I mean I think probably the 360 had
the you know the best game when I think
back on on a generation of games the 360
was like that was it that you'd like I
don't think there's been a generation
like that in terms of all the great
games but my favorite console was the OG
Xbox just the memories I have of the
first Halo and like
just playing it with all my friends and
like yeah like nothing beat that beats
those memories so yeah I'd have to go
with OJ Xbox absolute very very unique I
love it I love it shout out to ksr he
definitely approves I love this man OG
Xbox if you like to customize okay I see
you Lord the dean where do you sit
favorite console of all time and why
it's got to be the mega drive for me
yeah so I think it was legit did you
guys call it Genesis
that one for me I think it was because
it was like my most formative Years of
Gaming where like you know when I when I
was like 10 11 12 13 and it was just the
games there were just so many good games
on it you know and it was and it was
games like the first time that there
were games that you could play with
someone like two player yes
um you know sitting next to you and a
kind of age where I was like wanting to
do that kind of Competitive Gaming like
you know NBA jam with your best friend
like on a couch there's no beating there
and there were just so many good games
like that to play absolutely so yeah it
always holds a special place in my heart
when I could drive no bro I'm glad you
said that because I'm a huge for us in
the states Genesis that was my heart
that was when I saw the jump right and I
saw the graphical Fidelity and then it
said such a plethora of game the co-op
the couch gaming the second controller
with the friends you know even the the
uh the packing at the time was Altered
Beast which obviously actually you had
two players stuff I remember the golden
axes the streets the list goes on this
trip golden ax was so good oh so good so
good tremendous man loved it here my
joint was Castlevania bloodline oh yeah
yeah yes oh yeah yeah classic classic no
doubt no doubt and absolute pleasure to
have the Lords of the Volari in the
realm tell the five people where they
could find you what you got going on and
about this amazing product before you
head out
so our all our socials are just the
Volaris so at the Volare you can find us
on Twitter on
um Instagram on Tick Tock Although our
Tick Tock is severely lacking we need to
work
soon
yeah yeah yeah soon soon we're gonna
work better on our Tick Tock game but
yeah that's us uh you know the website
the valari.com
um we have a great uh Black Friday sale
on at the moment so you get uh 20 off
for if you order two pillows and free
shipping in the US
um so yeah that's that's the Volari it's
been an honor being here I I the the
first of many podcasts we hope this is
our first podcast so
um so it's in order for for it to be
with the Lords uh absolutely the best
podcast
yeah really happy to have been here guys
and
um yeah thanks for having us absolutely
I likewise thank you so much guys I was
not gonna miss today yeah a lot like I
really I just I just love the fact you
know let's be honest kids I like
sometimes you know you get processed you
could tell like the people are not
Gamers isn't it yeah and it's like I
love when it's when it's our Brethren
you know what I'm saying it come from
the culture that truly play these games
and it was really humbling to hear you
know you guys said that hey you listened
to us for a long time and like I said
looking to do great things together and
and I'm against super support of the
product huge fans we gotta watch your
journey continue to chart and uh yeah
make sure like I said if you're
interested you hear anything so you go
follow the socials we put the
information out there go check them out
and again if you're looking for that
exclusive deals right now right now
it's not a problem if you don't like it
send it right back send it right back
because you know we the Lords we have a
lot of you know EU Lords yes
it's coming it's coming don't worry
we're we are we are well aware of our UK
and our EU yes uh customers who really
want their pillows yes uh we are
actually probably in early January gonna
open up
um
uh shipping from the U.S uh because a
few people have asked us even though
it's expensive they want to be able to
get it uh you know we we don't stock
right now in the UK and EU but if you
want to order one and you don't want to
wait till we do stock so we're planning
on Stocking probably around uh the
beginning of Q2 okay next year okay um
so you know end of spring beginning of
summer we expect to have stock in the UK
and EU so if you wait till then then uh
you know shipping will be either
um free or a very small amount nice
um but for those of you who don't want
to wait like we had a customer from
Germany yesterday who was like I don't
want to wait I'll pay the the 40 or
whatever it is just get it to me now get
it down
others like that let us know we'll get
you a pillow no doubt no doubt we put
the information on the website go check
that out for our International launch we
just can't wait they just you know they
they need they need the pillow now and
absolute pleasure Brothers thank you so
much yeah you guys respect the time
difference and again we will be talking
we'll be seeing you guys at a couple of
functions in real life for sure oh yes
for sure we'll definitely meet up at the
next at the next packs oh yeah paxis is
going down it's going down have
ourselves a nice fat steak and some wine
oh yeah for sure oh for sure you know
we're gonna be talking some Sega stories
and I actually got to talk some gaming
with you a lot too as well looking
forward to our brothers enjoy your day
have a good one again the volari.com
thank you sorry for missing a lot of the
shows I feel horrible nah you good
Brothers you're good you're good so if
you want to get the super chat before
you head out yes sir so we're gonna have
too many we got the one that you read
from uh from Galveston to ten dollars if
you chat no doubt and then before then
we just got um not Jack two dollar super
chat but what about Sony's pillows
they got Xbox pillows stop playing yeah
I've got exclusive things
yeah I'm heading out my apologies I got
a little bit of a respite because uh
lady saw was not ready yet so she's got
a few minutes
I love you bro please I'll see you guys
next time no doubt we're gonna keep it
pushing no doubt we got the super chance
let me get the pole popping while we do
that
um last week's Pro results are in and
the people have spoken with Phil
Spence's latest interview stated the
importance of Microsoft's overall gaming
business which of these do you think is
most important to Xbox's long-term
success the winner of our four-way Iowa
people with 48 of the vote in over
1500 votes it's very engaged
tallied up was the messy Lords I don't
care all that sound nice but y'all
better have my AAA bangers group coming
in at second place with 28 of the vote
was develop the Xbox mobile storefront
group
in third place with 14 of the vote was
PC game pass growth group and in last
place at nine percent of the vote was
the most powerful console Hardware group
Lord attic the realm agrees with you
they don't want to hear nothing about
strategies where these Baggers at
he's been he's big time to get it sorry
I'm trying not to cough in the mic
um you know
I just I think that's just where
everyone is like you know I I give
Microsoft the benefits of the doubt
because I do feel like they're in a
better place than they were last
generation but until you actually see
the results of their fruit then it's
just like I ain't trying to hear no more
updates I ain't trying to hear no no
anything like that it's like I I want to
see why you ain't had a game of the year
up there for the past couple years like
until you show me that that
that results like at this point it's
just like you know I can't see I can't
hear another year this is the best year
of gaming I got it hey
no Dell shout out to calantis Lords
welcome to the realm no doubt and of
course my bed coming through the side
edge through the VIP levels cause you
already got that IOP intro we already
got the Royal Treatment so now he could
come through like the mob Kitchen in the
back you know what I'm saying it's
family room said okay Santi what's going
on brother how you doing uh this is
great to be on what's going on gentlemen
it is good to be on a Sunday this is
awesome to be here thank you so much
good to have you brother good for
holding us down you already know great
show yesterday by the way yeah thank you
thank you sir thank you I'm a lurker oh
we appreciate your lurking sir I
appreciate it maybe one day we'll we'll
have you coming officially yeah yeah
I got a big boy rounds too I got a big
one rounds too yeah sick as a dog but I
was like I'm lurking though no doubt let
me get a couple uh switch out before we
get next big one
um hug each oh actually welcome to the
brands but then hargit shanim my man
found out Super Chat Gotham Knights cold
with your oh he's blessing around right
now you got that Gotham Knights cold
he's got that was one over the store bro
yeah you know what's funny man I
wouldn't need it
I gotta go to the room you gotta go to
the road so look he got that new tales
of the borderline silver brother thank
you so much the way you always give back
to the community like truly we don't
give you your flowers right you really
always support this community much love
and of course pragmatic ego with that 10
super chat IOP is unrivaled in game talk
in interviews gas gaming events live
content merch review oh man Etc IOP is
the top of the top love y'all one oh man
one continues lessons
that means it really means a lot you
need to see y'all up in here regardless
man it really means a lot to us thank
you so much and uh yeah we gonna get
into some topics stuff going on King
imma set you up man because thank you
this this is you man this is this is
it's a big one we got some things to
read
Microsoft in the news again and the ever
going the ever born Saga that is that is
the Activision Blizzard cake man so it
appears that Microsoft says it offered
Sony a 10-year deal to keep Call of Duty
on PlayStation video game chronicle.com
Xbox told the New York Times that it
offered a 10-year deal to Sony on
November 11th so he has since declined
to comment on this claim Microsoft has
now accused Sony of misleading
Regulators stating that Sony has
overstated the importance of Call of
Duty to its viability PlayStation boss
Jim Ryan has since responded stating
that it's not true that Sony has misled
Regulators Microsoft is a tech giant
with a long history of dominating
Industries and it is highly likely that
the choices Gamers have today will
disappear if the deal goes ahead then we
have the political local news bombshell
that dropped later that week
um the ftcs look likely to file an
Anti-Trust lawsuit to block Microsoft's
69 billion dollar take over a video game
giant Activision Blizzard making some
hit games Call of Duty credit Crush
according to three people with knowledge
of the matter King he had jumped on this
topic the minute it was like Glenn
easily yeah
I said hey now what you said I saw your
messages you sent me
I said you know what I need to come out
and talk
it's absolutely inadequate why is 10
years inadequate for you Lord because
they know after that 10 years I'm dead
why can't you you survive after 10 years
of Call of Duty oh
there's absolutely no way in hell I'm
gonna go for No 10 years I want it for
life
you want it in perpetuity but let me
tell you something I don't even want it
what I just want to do is block them
all over them
no you know but I will say you're doing
a fantastic job because you actually
might cancel this thing
I'll get the FTC to just uh put a
non-compete Clause so wait wait hold up
like your whole goal is no matter what
the cost that you have to have Call of
Duty forever no I don't want call it I
don't want any I want this deal stop hey
why why would you even if that is I do
not want this deal to go through in any
shape form or fashion
do you understand what's up can you
explain to me book why this still needs
to be stopped is there any particular
reason or what's going on
a market that bad boy is mine I won't be
able to fool and bamboozle
I hear I hear a lot of the crowd bugs
say you know just go out and make your
own why don't you just do that did you
see what happened to Battlefield
that was you that put the battlefield
business up I think I'm gonna put Socom
out there to get slaughtered
y'all don't buy games you're not enough
so are you implying that there is
nothing that Saudi could make that
anyone can do can compete with Call of
Duty and thus you must block this deal I
don't want the deal go through it at all
I want I want them to fall to the floor
and look around and say we gotta
scramble you see you say you're wrong
Ed up on me and I told you I put my
money in the right place
you got your buddy with the EU and it's
starting to Regulators yeah FTC
I'm assuming Buck you're on like Plan D
what what what's what's the last plan
you got going to try to stop this deal
you see it you look at it you know it
they're talking about oh concessions I
don't want no consent so there's no
concession I don't want anything I want
it dead
I wanted do white is that the only
concession you want is done oh
to go right back to where we're gonna be
Call of Duty right over here
so Call of Duty or Playstation is this
important to you that you are willing to
just blow this whole thing Call of Duty
what you feel to realize this dude is
opening up a whole Mobile store and
they're gonna go get caned
and they're going to go Slaughter us I
don't need that in my life so this is
the last generation for us I got a
question for buck okay
let's say the deal gets canceled don't
aren't you scared that maybe you you
have damaged your relationship yeah like
you're throwing so many people
contract Service but Buck you said
yourself there's nothing that anybody
else can do and you just saw a Bungie
and you have all these great Studios
nothing anyone else can do can can match
the the the sheer magnitude
again I would like you all to know no
matter what deal they put across that
day well I'm gonna say no
shout out to you shout out to you for
blocking and play put your money where
where you need to go no doubt oh no
you've heard it here for buck his uh
attentions are clear sodi brass that uh
it's it's all about blocking the deal
and no matter what the cost we got our
two amazing guests for us again a shout
out to the awesome the action Luke
I don't know how I made it through that
I don't know how I made it through that
without coughing and dying ah you good
bro I appreciate the Volcan for us for
the sis how you you doing hey can you
guys hear me yeah turn yourself up a
little bit turn yourself off just a
little bit and I don't know how Zoom
works oh there you go yeah there you go
all right all right hi what's going on
what's going on you know we talking that
talk cause games going on deals getting
blocked and stuff like that where do you
sit on all lists of potential you know
Call of Duty the the statement that it
was potentially offered for 10 years and
maybe that so Sony declined the comment
so potentially maybe that they did not
agree to that you know concession so to
speak listen uh we all know that uh Jim
Lyon Ryan one of my favorite Liars one
of my favorite Liars uh in this industry
of course of course they wouldn't be uh
love that it makes sense like ever
everything that's come out with Jim even
coming through the complain about in the
first place I'm not really surprised
like at the end of the day they want
Call of Duty on Playstation forever you
know like there's no deal to be made
they're like no no
this is our this when people think of
Call of Duty they think of PlayStation
at least at this point after the PS4
generation you know what I'm saying so
I'm not really I'm not really surprised
honestly speaking and they're little
nasty little XP booster uh over there
you know what I'm saying I was like I
was like hello
I just started playing Cod I'm on the
box obviously right and I'm just like
looking through what they get over on
Playstation I'm just like God
are you implying that they have
exclusive practices yes
it's not there's no implications flat
out okay like the audacity the nerve we
just want to protect the consumer they
want to protect their consumers
specifically which I mean I get it big
business I understand I understand but
what about everybody else huh
no it's like I just listen
you think they care about day consumers
no I think it's more of uh they care
about taking money from their concerns
thank you thank you it's it's about uh
this
an air this front you know what I'm
saying because like everything that's
come out of their mouths I'm just like
man that uh does not make any sense you
make any sense whatsoever especially
like things like this I'm over here
looking I'm getting the Callisto
protocol you know and then I see that
they have like I think they have like an
exclusive skin or something over there
yeah they do it they do it this is deaf
animations right okay let's see always
doing something over there they got an
exclusive mission in Harry Potter like
yeah it's like I said that they're
signing these they're signing these
deals and and scheduling these
appointments to talk about we don't want
exclusivity at the same time like
they're bashing Microsoft on Twitter
with one hand and the other hand they
signing deals getting exclusive content
their own platform like
so pretty much your thought process is
you feel kind of hypocritical what they
do I mean I I like I absolutely think
it's typical I'm not really surprised
though it is like I don't think much of
big business in general you know what
I'm saying so it's just it is what it is
I would be interested to see if they
would
I just can't imagine that Microsoft
would start the process on this deal in
the first place if they didn't think it
was going to go through you know if they
didn't have their lawyers set up like
okay we know that there's going to be
some nonsense there but like what's the
likelihood of success for this oh okay
we got it we got it all right bet you
know so I don't think they they thought
this level of snitching was going to be
a problem I actually have to agree I
don't think that Microsoft probably
expected like this public outcry by by
multiple parties like you know it's a
possibility they did but you know it's
just like it's kind of crazy I've never
seen a company like be litter themselves
so much just to try to cancel a deal
like they don't care the same face they
don't care for nothing they please don't
take it from us please oh my God please
I
would say that they consider it all
possibilities yeah yeah I don't think
that considering how much money it is I
don't think they would have been like
yeah there's just no no possibility that
people are going to have an issue with
this like you know what I'm saying so I
think they considered all that stuff
right before they uh started putting it
in the works I feel you I feel Lord K
Asante pulling up
what's your thoughts on it man there's a
lot that's developed right the ongoing
saga like what's your thoughts of the
10-year deal potentially you know
um not agree to that uh Microsoft says
they offered on November 11th as well as
the political article saying about
potential deal blocking likely so so I
agree but by and large with everybody on
here I actually think it's pretty pretty
interesting and pretty hilarious uh if
you obviously those of us who pay
attention to the balls and Strikes you
know we see you know as Luca has said
you see it and you see the hypocrisy and
all of this what I think is funny and
and shout out to my International
viewers I'm sure there's many of you out
there during World Cup season I think
this this analogy will be apt if you're
watching if you see the man down the
field and he's let's say Ronaldo's down
the field there and he grabs a leg he
grabs a knee and he falls down and he's
being dramatic it's part of the game
baby
right but it's not up to him to
determine whether or not that is that is
the narrative that moves forward it's up
to the referee is to actually have eyes
that are open and stay open and go yeah
you get off your butt and keep moving
right if if he doesn't do that and he
gives you the foul you hate on him but
still that's just the nature of the game
so to me you know Jim is out here being
Jim Ryan you know at this point not only
has he grabbed the knee they got
crutches going they're doing the whole
thing right that's what they're doing
here you know is it hilarious obviously
we see that it's hilarious they
literally documented everything they've
been doing to the others for 30 years
and said please don't let them do that
to us you know we see that but if they
get away with it the question shouldn't
be oh lion snitch and dance moves Ryan
it should be where do the eyes go the
referees like what's going on here you
know what I'm saying that's that's what
I'm that's where I'm at with it you know
to me it's interesting that they're able
to weaponize these regulatory bodies
seemingly because and everyone always
tells me to to always preface my my
statement with seemingly
are you implied
it's not seemingly if they got
PlayStations to say my place
it's not seemingly if you said you know
I want to preserve my PlayStation you
see mortality in your future
you both implying that the CMA is
influenced or a parody the exact
concerns well you know you know so so
far where we're going down the line and
and let's be fair right because uh uh um
uh if you do some some some viewing
through the cma's Twitter Twitter feed
there is a history of oh they're getting
hot they're getting hot oh it's gonna be
crazy to see here all as well like
they've done that on a few occasions
right so we are on that trajectory we
just don't know where we will land so we
will crystallize our thoughts once we
get that final statement but it's
seeming like it's heading in certain
directions which seems very interesting
to me because obviously anyone who pays
you know a cursory glance at the
situation you pay attention for just a
little bit you see the hypocrisy left
and right as as it's being spilled onto
the streets here all over the place
right now now to the question quickly to
the question of did Microsoft expect all
of this oh I suspect they expected all
of this especially that last one
especially that last 10-year thing it
was like well we gave him a deal no we
we gave him five years oh and and every
and every line right at every step as
soon as it does it you know you got Jim
coming out here going nah man that that
ain't right that's just unacceptable
right then you got a little further and
there's still there's more dashing of
the of the statements and then they drop
that 10 years on the statement on the
table right and it's just nothing it's
quiet right because at this point if you
really think about it they have nothing
to lose and everything to gain so if
they take that 10 years immediately oh
okay the problem solved because they
were the only ones complaining clearly
right right yeah if they say it's
unacceptable that means then everyone
can look at you and go 10 Years bro
really
right so they could they can wait right
now until the dust settles and see where
all the chips fall because it seems like
it's heading in their Direction and
right at that last minute when they
think they ain't got much else to go
they go well you know that 10 years we
didn't really say much about that right
they can take it later right so so to me
it's very strategic on both sides of the
house and Microsoft is like oh Cod is
your issue yeah pay attention to cot
they had 10 years on the DACA from day
one keep paying it oh King can't got
nothing to do with it
you know what I'm saying like they both
have very strategic aims here and at the
end of the day I'm sure PlayStation will
go feeling fat fat cat saying hey we got
10 years out of them and then at
Microsoft to go yeah we had them 10
years on the docker from day one and
they took it and that's how it'll slide
I suspect I like the thought Pro I
wanted I want to push back I would I
want to challenge all of you yes and and
I I know where you go if I saw and I
love the logic is Sound Logic is very
sound what I wanted to push back is what
do you say to to Baby the potential
mindset of like what king was saying
like how Buck was here talking about
what to block it at all costs that that
20 years is not not the end game the end
game is the status quo block it
completely yes yes okay so yeah and I I
agree with that because I don't think
they came in with that power but after
all the tea has been spilled and all the
problems all in the street right we see
that at first it was let's see how much
blood we can draw now it's yo we have
the whole game to win so 10 years what
it was what is 10 years but they didn't
say they didn't come out what makes me
think that that is that is that the
chicken that they're playing with their
competitor they didn't come out outright
like they've done before and go 10 years
get out of here with that right there
were mums the word right so at the end
if 10 years is all we can get I guess
that's that's good right but but as of
right now the wind is at our back the
CMA speaking using our words let's see
how far we can go with this thing before
we you know concede to 10 years that's
what seems like to me okay now I hear
you going Lord attic Man 10 years on the
table potentially not enough decline in
common Politico putting out statements
likely to get blocked what do you think
Jim Ryan needs a raise oh yeah he will
he move into these streets they do that
dude is like walking with the machine
keep throwing wrenches
he's trying to throw the biggest wrench
but he's like having it's a little heavy
so yeah it is what it is I I do think
the deal probably most likely is still
going to go through but I would be very
interested if like
the the moves of one company
dethrows a billion dollar deal like this
it would be kind of crazy all we gonna
have to respect Luke are we gonna have
to respect Jim Ryan's head if the
blocking go down
listen
um you know at the end of the day if as
long as he gets the job done I guess but
the whole the crying thing about I'm I
don't know
why are you not feeling it
absolutely not Ricky could come through
with a little bit more dignity but I
guess you know when you have that kind
of money you're just flies out the
window I'm not sure you know what I'm
saying but look it ain't no borrows this
has been this you're trying to get the
stakeholders just we gotta shut it down
we need this money
that's it I mean would I'd be like wow
that's impressive that you were able to
get like you were part of the factor
yeah absolutely okay but that doesn't
mean
doesn't mean anything I'm just gonna be
looking at him like well Jim crying lion
Ryan you know what I'm saying I'm like
it is what it is man don't look at the
dance moves come on
it's like it's like and when you're
playing Halo and they spawn the rocket
launch in the middle of the screen and
you like oh we got to get that rocket
launcher because you know once you get
that rocket launch is obliteration
let's get that rocket launcher
I'm very interested if Microsoft has had
conversations on what happens if it gets
right I'll ask the question yeah they
reinvest that money like
or you know maybe they they cool down on
the buying stuff because that's a lot of
money they lost from buying that trying
to buy that I'm curious on what their
mindset is on the contingency plans
because
you know
I'm not going to say that but it is
I feel like
from a Sony Fanboy what I've been
hearing can't you hear it you don't want
that deal now to go oh wait wait are you
implying that Sony don't want that smoke
with Microsoft that they they better
chill they better call or they push it
too far are we applying it's one of
those things where I'm pretty sure
there's already contingency plans it's
like obviously when it comes to
Acquisitions and stuff none of them are
in stone
but there's going to be money throwing
around attic shot face 23 BK and why 20
Super Chat he said Xbox Call of Duty is
it relevant also Xbox or games ain't as
good as PlayStation so that's what he's
saying yeah Call of Duty sells more than
all those combined though so yeah that
deal don't go through what's gonna
happen for 17 bumps what is going on why
am I here saying okay that deal will go
through Sega get purchase Square again
you a fly King is a scorched Earth
philosophy if you get blocked don't let
them block it cause they go go crazy you
stop this wedding
you stop this when you stand up and said
I got objections you know to this
wedding she was mine first all that crap
that you won't say you stopped this
winner see what they're gonna do because
it's it's the large cash that is
bringing the eyes you know my kid when
you brought Bungie for three point
something billion right nobody cared
right they was like oh yeah let that
happen that's that's chump change 70
billion dollars people looked over like
I know they had that much bread to
spread like that what's up
they pocket watch it like crazy okay
okay I'm gonna tell you right now that's
70 billion turns into a bunch of little
three billions all over the place and
that's when you
single-handedly you know how you cut off
your nose and spite your face my mama
always told me that okay okay don't cut
off your nose and spite your face that
dude gave you a good deal he told you
for as long as you're around now you
ain't gonna be the CEO of that company
that much longer anyway so why are you
worrying about but I understand you want
to make sure your golden parachute is
good for later
Call of Duty exists it's over it's over
this
get at it I'm kind of curious
if it doesn't go through
does out of spite the moment that Call
of Duty deal is over they just
proactively offer the marketing to
Microsoft like because obviously it just
I do think there is a point of money
contingency on that but it's just like
I if the board truly wants that deal to
go through and everyone on Activision of
blizzard and King wants that deal to go
through do you hand the marketing to the
people whose cost you a 83 billion
dollars
in the next the next deal I got a lucky
question to follow up to yours I like
when you're going You're Gonna like the
poll today so my question you addict is
and let's just say Sony pushes it and
they're in the regulator's air and the
record says okay look but we we you get
one concession and we get this one
concession
Microsoft forget what they want and
you'll get what you want let's say
Sony's concession is okay
you gotta not only have it on Game Pass
it gotta be your PlayStation Plus or
or it can't be in Game Pass then we
don't know what to do
you take it out of Game Pass King you
can have you to tell me what to do with
my 70 billion dollars nobody cared what
you did with Bungie who the hell are you
telling me what to do with my food once
I buy it I choose not to give it to you
I don't choose to give it to you but
he's brought a bag of potato chips and I
choose not to share you ain't getting
nothing but you bought Walmart you put
the whole Walmart yo I'm just so sick
and tired of these dudes begging and
crying he gave me 10 years man hold up
10 years and go away that's all
it's just it gets to the point right now
and then you got these stupid dudes in
my DMs
see King this is what we do king you
and that's all you want to do so if this
deal don't go through you're gonna
Champion a snitch so go out there and
get a six nine tattoo on your face
exactly you rapping right you're about
to go play gumbo
so don't act like you don't like
snitching and then you're gonna sit here
and rip but don't don't take snitching
when it's convenient your convenient
snitch but they said they harming Gamers
Gamers you know who's homing Gamers you
see that pistol PlayStation Plus that's
over there that's harming game that's
harming Gamers put not putting your
first title uh first party titles inside
your system that's that's harm and
Gamers paying 70 for a game that's
harming games prices on your console
that's harming games so don't sit over
here talking about oh we for the people
you are not you are for the people
that's in that board
outside buying consoles and I want to
know when are you idiots gonna wake up
so he's a country club
he got sick for that boy King was like
yeah
listen man
I love it we love the passion brother we
love it I know I know you're sick of the
fact that you're still here I'm just
happy that you're here okay sorry so
like the concession part like they like
yo we'll let it go through
but you can't have it in that game pass
what's the word what's the first yeah
see so so I don't know I don't know so
okay so myself and as you know myself
and Mr ever going soccer we go back and
forth with this one frequently yes
pretty frequently we go back and forth
on the end and I have been always on
this and and he agrees with me which
which you know that that's a rare that's
a rarity you know it is what it is by
and large they are here to build a
platform yes they've been cow talented
platforms for a while now they count
down to iOS they hate that they count
how to Android they hate that they've
had their own platforms that they've had
to let go of because they struck when
the iron's hot and in some in some
circles they say when you strike when
it's too early it's the same thing as
being wrong right so they have to now
deal with others and their platforms
this is the closest they've come to
having their own established platform
and as such through hooker crook through
billions of dollars spent they're going
to solidify this as a platform right but
in order for them to be able to continue
and solidify that as a full-fledged
platform that others will have to come
to they have to be able to stay Dynamic
and I suspect I could be wrong but I
suspect which is telling them where to
place or not to place their plan their
their uh their
catalog that would be a bridge too far
hence they started throwing out
concessions before anybody actually
officially said something right so
instead that's why they kept going well
we don't need concessions that's why the
CEOs come out and saying that right all
the while they say hey we'll offer it
two years um uh three years after oh
we'll offer five years after oh heck
let's throw it down we're all for 10
years has anyone actually asked for
actual concessions to be written no
they're just throwing it out there to
negate any kind of argument you can come
out with right now so if after all that
you go nah fam you're not putting in
Game Pass that's when them lawyers will
come out oh there we go to court I'll
see you to cook that's what that's when
that's when that's when The Killers came
see now that's the thing right and I've
been talking about talking about it with
other other folks as well I find it
super interesting in in the States you
know uh everyone I see he I see he's out
there
in the chat's fair there he suspects
that it like some um the political
article was a strategic drop just to
kind of show hey we we mean business but
around here you know you got your verbal
ninjas we got off let's see where we go
right okay I don't see that in the cma's
world right you can you can you can go
and complain on process but after that
you know they make their determination
you kind of Sol as it were right I have
not seen any any more you know options
available there so this whole thing is
super interesting to me yeah but I do
suspect that you know hey we're telling
you where to put your 70 Milli yeah that
may be a bridge too far that's when the
ninjas start coming out that's when the
cognitos start coming out and start
having conversation you gotta have talks
got to talk about it I'll keep it brief
I mean this was very interesting this
week just to see how this stuff play out
you know when you hear about the 10
years you know Microsoft to me has been
trying to be as transparent as possible
with their intention to say look we're
not going to pull this away from you we
we gonna Minecraft this right you don't
gotta worry you know it's good right and
to be the declining of comment to the 10
years is ex specifically significant
because because that to me says they are
not taking that deal and when they're
not taking 10 years then my mind starts
to go okay this is scorched Earth this
is I'm gonna take a bet
I may have some influence in the region
because I've always said that God has
always been on record to say everyone's
clowning Jim Ryan I know but this lady
look everybody was clouding I get it we
he's a he's a funny individual to follow
I will admit he's absolutely hilarious
but I've always told people this is the
same man who's elevated in the Sony
building because of the EU influence and
making them a dominant Force this is a
man that was able to shift their kind of
tradition from Japan over to the EU and
say this is the money making let's be
honest his Ascension is kind of
warranted based on how they dominated
last generation in that region so to me
this is a man that has pulled and
building and pulling the region right
when we hear certain entities using
Expressions by console and it do look
spooky but moving on at the end of the
day the thing I will say is that I do
respect his hand that way and this is a
businessman this is a money man this is
about his job is to the stakeholder is
hook a crook whatever we doing it's got
to be in our best interest and to have
Call of Duty on your platform and you
got this tremendous Revenue just flowing
in the PlayStation just for it existing
you ain't got to do no legwork you got
the marketing right people let's be real
right look at and cancel like we're
hardcore Gamers all of us
but the Casual when you added marketing
rights the casuals associate that as
almost like an exclusive right because
you see the PlayStation logo on the
bottom Call of Duty and then like Luca
elegantly put out
they've been known how this map have
this content have this I mean look we
come from the destiny days we know we
know how bad it is man you know about it
you ain't getting that Hawk wound you
ain't getting the maps oh my destiny 2
come out okay now you guys
die every day B I feel that so they've
been known to play this game with that
so that's the hypocrisy part I have to
give you all that that is literally
their entire business model is set on
his dance moves
Billy Jeanette how he's able to put a
little bit of James Brown on it cake you
know what's gays gotta respect the
hustle you gotta respect it because
clearly no disrespect that region isn't
as versed in game the fact that we hear
Phil gotta go over there and bring a
switch a Playstation Xbox and show them
how the Dynamics in the games
PlayStation is that's PlayStation's
region right so if you're on their home
turf of course you're gonna get the most
opposition on their home turf right so
we expected this to happen but what we
didn't expect that let's keep it above
let's go we didn't expect this dude to
lose all dignity
like really like and I'm just saying it
to say this I know that's like kind of
rough and hard
what the moment you say because he told
you guys y'all weren't enough right
there's nothing we could do that could
make nothing we could do so he is a a a
forever pessimist right because we just
brought Bungie they can't make anything
you can't do that we just brought this
other Studio they can't do anything
they snitch all over here so
it's I didn't I didn't expect this yeah
right I did I really didn't expect this
but again like y'all said he doesn't
play video games so he doesn't care
about his standing in the gaming
community
may I interject just for a moment and
say why are you surprised that why were
you not expecting this in every instance
right in the pr game it seems that
Microsoft is always trying to be the Mia
culpa to the point where it got annoying
right yeah but they have enjoyed Sony
has and Jim specifically has enjoyed
that aggressive posture at all points
even when it's out and out raw and
everybody feels feels grimy about it
they go yeah we did it for our Gamers
they enjoy being dirty and having
everyone see that they're being dirty
and it's just like yeah well we want so
deal with it that's what they do so it's
and I always say the staff of one they
both Microsoft and Sony keep training
their consumers to expect certain things
you said grooming them oh
look at the Tomb Raider example yeah
they took a two-year two-year exclusive
and it was scorched Earth everywhere
Sony doesn't it yes it's part of part of
the part impossible yeah we do exactly
so
little dog that couldn't yeah so when
this whole thing started popping off my
surprise is that everybody else is
surprised that they are so dirty it's
what they do they have always done that
and every time they do it their fans go
yup they standing behind us right well I
mean I think the interesting part again
this is for the CMA to decide is you
know the the obviously the influence
that they're putting out there and you
know is this illegal is this something
that needs to be blocked or is it a
situation we're gonna block it for the
intent of the concessions and what the
concessions are I think that's really
what it comes down to again it's clearly
Scorch Earth policy I will say this
though I still think as much as the
political article came out and said
likely I big the fact that we were in
phase two already knew that this is
going to go into intense scrutiny this
is going to go much longer because I
mean a lot of people were popping
bottles after they went through Brazil
and was like yo just a couple more left
we might get you know what I'm saying
Diablo bottle Warfare gonna be in Game
Pass come the holiday and I was like
relax fam I I think this is going to be
a much longer process right because at
the end of the day there's still all
these regulated bodies that have to be
appeased and have to be and then we got
to talk about the political climate
right that you know they're coming after
big Tech right they're going to want to
make sure that I will say this I do
think the the part I don't agree with
the other stuff is very hypocritical to
me but the part about the cloud being an
emergent market and I'm having Azure is
something I understand you got to look
through and it's a new market that no
one's in the space and obviously we have
a lottery we joke about them you know
being the first you know gaming pillow
with his face you go ahead and see if
they look at you but at the end of the
day you know it is interesting that they
may have to see okay because they have
this infrastructure and if they have
this service you know could it get out
ahead I do understand that I'm not going
to be you know hypocritical there so I
understand the extra eye but yeah it's
going to be interesting I still think
that this is par for the course deeper
investigation see what happens Microsoft
like saying somebody said is going to
have to present and they probably were
prepared for this moment you know what
I'm saying on some level but I do agree
with King on this
I understand the the the game is the
game and it's dirty out here but I have
to admit I am surprised at the level of
intensity and the level of oh Nintendo
they're trying to make a certain time
that don't mean anything and and and and
you know PlayStation Plus and we like
the the things that they're saying
is very pointed to an audience that may
not be as educated in the space and if
you have influenced I I am concerned
that you can lean things a certain way
so let's see let's see how this thing
goes but fun times for the uh for the
Regulators get a couple super checklists
anybody else got anything else for you
before oh shout out to hockey Janine 17
months attic I need some help with these
chats they flying in I got some PS just
detailed how their own business
practices are anti-consumer and
anti-competitive I expect Regulators
around the world to put the pieces
together PlayStation should watch out
fines coming I mean he does got a good
point about how they thought a lot of
people under the bus and these are the
same people they have relationships with
but that's neither here no their Max
arthy five pound super shot PlayStation
for the players if we have access to
Quality
messy call Andrews Jr 2007 chat Sony
acquired Bungie and nobody said a word
oh the Joker quote okay slow mo backslap
level for 29 months and scum cast member
who's that tiny person in the car oh
there we go here we go man
get him sis get him always something you
know if you came on the show and all we
saw we were at busted ankles then yeah
you would know that it's slow-mo okay hi
what's up what's up bro what's good hey
yo yo she came fast she gave him shout
out this little before the legend five
dollar Super Chat activator said they
will go to war for Xbox if it is
necessary the way I see it Jim Ryan is
digging himself a grave they want to get
married you ain't gonna stop us ready
all right because last time I checked
Microsoft said they was going to give
them uh 97 uh dollars on the on on the
shares and these shares dropped down to
78. Michael's upset don't worry about
that we got that big check boo-boo we
got you come on
did you see the Activision
um comment I believe the uh name now
yeah yeah she was talking about she's
ready to fight if need be she's been out
there being a little spicy with her
words left and right people just haven't
been paying attention till now they look
around and all of a sudden they're going
hey she's ready to fight it makes sense
right you know I I it's all business and
we know ultimately it is all business
but it is very interesting the thought
process of you know the scorched Earth
and how it will leave things you know in
that thought process of okay so you're
successful at at uh at killing the deal
not only will Jim Jim Ryan be on the
Mount Rushmore of snitches oh and and
CEOs that need to be that need to be you
know
let me come on now that would be
imaginative Frank Lucas six nine Mickey
bonds
but it's an achievement to be no for
sure I mean I got to put time with kids
on this is complete
after that though how is your
relationship with this company that
you've been you've been working with for
so many years right and and to the point
of like the 30 I think it's even beyond
the 30 right it is it is that a symbol
that they will lose right uh you know by
by and large they become reference
designs it's it's usually PlayStation
first yes and then everyone else you
know when that huge monster moves and
when it moves it'll move permanently
right it's not one of those oh you lost
the deal this time yeah no it's done
right
exactly right so I think that that's why
they're in that that moment catch me
outside how about that
I can't move it over your baby father
with the five dollars in the chat 10
years is longer than most marriages last
these days Sony better stop playing
games before Microsoft gold Scorch earth
king burn them down buy them and shut
the doors
and you think the CMA will let that
happen hell no but they don't care
hostile takeover send a couple of people
in to buy some stuff and sell the stocks
over to you then you go in there move
out and eat them out I can tell you how
to do it get it done
36 month chat from uh thank you if the
deal gets blocked this is the time I
want Microsoft be extra Petty and invest
that money to lock call it up for the
next 10 years you get every other game
and uh that makes money for some uh for
dying songs it'd be crazy if they if if
a corporation does let that pettiness go
on and they like also take over like
Square Enix or something
it's it's it's not pettiness you costing
them bread yeah you've really costing
these dudes money like the board and
everybody everybody working there is
about to get a bump up and go to a
better working condition so you're on
the outside saying we we like how you
work we like the messiness that's going
on over there we like how it's
inequality and all this other stuff
that's going on over there and we don't
want you to be able to pay mortgage we
want you to stay exactly how you are
giving us money and that's it and I
think the bigger problem is that because
you get people that's vindictive and
evil and they say oh he stopped this
from happening on God
we got to see it it's this
man if Dale Falls they buy uh embracer
non-traded Company Five Dollar super
drive from ever born Saga if you end up
getting Sega as a result of the ABK
getting blocked worth the hashtag the
book of everborn
two Super Chat from Jim Bratt bastard
Ryan wow King stop calling PS Plus or
I'll tell my mommy okay okay that was
kind of weird
um
then we got a five dollar subscribe from
clutch Man Zero one
Sony is like that one person out of the
crowd who objects to a wedding because
they won't uh because they want
everything that they want won't no it's
it's about the role yeah they want
everything that the wife is going to
enjoy for their whole life Wow
anyway and then we got Ronka looks like
rank uh 23 files which FDC gets
obliterated if this goes to court no
real legal basis for challenge sir X-Man
two and awesome chat correction embrace
your group abrasive group is a traded
company Okay C W two dollars Jim is only
using 0.0001 of his snitch power wow he
thought about his final form we're not
at the final form okay okay hold on I
got a shout out to my man uh look post
up keep hitting me up the merger
agreement says that the big three has to
be approved for it to go through USC k u
a the governing bodies are cool but not
that important okay okay some news I
guess must be breaking shout out the
first second
chat that was low Luca like your height
and tremends he's out of pocket right
he said what he had to say no doubt no
doubt called we we I believe follow chat
they're lucky they're dealing with Phil
and not Peter Moore Peter Moore was
ruthless his everybody has wait insane
Freedom woman's in his bag crazy but I
think that they doing it supposed to do
the right thing though I think actually
his approach isn't probably better in
this situation diplomatic you know what
you got handled it the right way plus
they got eyes on them too defenses I
don't think we get to where we was at if
there's Peter more there's different
hands for different jobs I respect that
yeah Peter Moore got the 360s this Great
era ever and it made them superiorly you
know relevant in that category so no
doubt cool we got to move on respect
lady Lucas time if she's got one more
talking topic or she's got a garage with
respective time before we move on how
you doing sis I'm good foreign
games man anticipation things we looking
for things you hyped for where you at
you just set it up because I only got it
like I got a battery on my voice
keep it simple this was a fun one you
know 2023 is approaching and we couldn't
approach it any way we want we're gonna
do kind of like our top five or top
three most anticipated games coming into
next year as the year is closing up now
let's start mess this lady Luca like
what you what's your hype for for next
year what's some of them titles that you
most anticipated
so I'm looking forward to Starfield uh
obviously I I can't wait for that I am a
fan of Bethesda
um put like 200 hours in Fallout 4.
I played through Skyrim uh
yeah yeah I I I'm looking forward to I'm
looking forward to Starfield I like the
little that we've seen so far I'm like
okay this looks
like Peak Bethesda I'm good with it like
I'm good with going into it because of
that so looking forward to that and then
I am a huge huge huge huge huge huge
huge fan of Dead Space uh so I'm looking
forward to that remake I've wanted a
dead space remake for years now like
don't get me wrong I think the Dead
Space franchise still holds up to this
day like I can go but I actually went
back a few years ago and I played
through the games again you know and I
had a blast doing so so they're great
but just seeing what they've done with
those visuals I can't wait man I can't
wait for that look at five lucky five no
doubt strong I love it I love it quick
question before I pass up
let's just say I'm going to talk to my
Starfield Pete because I know he was he
was gang gang and stuff so we did we on
the same side here well they ask you
what would you feel if um there is no
performance mode on Starfield I'm
getting it on PC
it seems like [ __ ] ain't got nothing to
do with me that's your problem
what performance mode I don't know what
that is oh you don't know what that is
okay okay yeah
she's like that those are problems I do
not understand yeah
so it's not there I will play that way
no no no
okay any game that that comes out and
doesn't have a performance mode I'm
getting the game on PC wait hold on I
gotta cover for my man this is my
brother from another mother but he is
frauding right now and I gotta come for
him I said I I don't I don't support 30
friend games on Console it's not 30
that's what we thought yeah I have no
problem going to PC if it's for a game
I'm passionate about but plague was not
one of those games
okay I'm learning a lot of things today
okay okay they're gonna go over the feet
I'm just restating stuff I've said
it's missing I'm gonna shout slow won't
be a messy PC Mastery how they got it
okay okay I mean what about you what are
you gonna do if it doesn't have a
performance mode
like I've been a record for betraying
Xbox with the destiny days with I was
very angry when the series X
did not I mean excuse me the the Xbox
One X did not have a performance mode
you know I'm not attacked I I felt that
it could have been pushed you know even
though they gave me 45. I'm Sony you
know what I'm saying oh you go to the
parody Clause okay I see what you do I
see you doing you know back that day was
yeah they had to explain on the courts
so you know the flag on the porch
day down attic just use a proper
reference when it came to sports God
bless you God bless you guys
but yo I know sis you was mad at me I
was mad at you I was like okay so when
are we gonna play and you're just like
all right so pc
pc it's like daughter talk Who coming at
me in the comments said attic capping
he's playing Pokemon at 15 first that's
because there's no other option to play
this game there will be options to play
Starfield I don't have to play that on
Console you don't think I would have
played if if there was if uh Mario Spark
whatever that game was called if that
was on PC I would have played that on PC
if Pokemon was on PC I had to play that
on PC there ain't no other option so I
gotta play that listen about no other
options the beauty the beauty of Xboxes
I have the option to do to play the game
where I choose so let's see what happens
but hopefully yeah I mean somebody's
showing that steam deck you see yeah
there are some options
that's uh does Fallout 4 have a
performance mode now that they pushed
yeah yeah oh I mean I'm I'm
it'll probably come with a performance
melt then I wouldn't be too cons I
wouldn't be too concerned
pardon me Grace because I feel like they
they've gotten a lot of I mean we just
saw the Gotham night stuff so it's just
like I feel like okay sir if you didn't
look at that whole scenario not feel
like your game needs performance well
you're not paying attention to the
ground I think it's about looking like
whatever you just doing so much they see
this thing is taking off the chips and
and colonies and Bethesda and dialogue
choices open world bro there's a lot of
CPU
that's an all that's also an Xbox series
X okay that's not oh yeah
so there's no reason there's no reason
good point no Xbox see what happens but
that's why Matt shout out if you ever
put it I got it and how much how much
you want about that stories in it was
delayed to make sure it can get well
because it originally it was supposed to
come out for the last gen but it was the
you know when it was delayed they
announced it was coming out only for
next gen well current gen at this point
so you know maybe that was one of the
reasons that you know they wanted to
make sure that the book phased uh skip
star field it ran smooth you know we we
all have hopes and dreams
you need more time to get your frames up
I'm all for it yeah they also they did
the same thing with Fallout 4. they uh
they were like it's just going to be on
next-gen consoles when it came out so
good hope there no doubt case
give me uh maybe a couple of Highly
anticipated 2023 games that you're
looking for uh so my my first
anticipated 2023 game was my most
anticipated 2022 game and my most
anticipated 2021 game oh damn I have
watched this game at least I've had I've
had at least one hour of footage
floating around YouTube for at least
since 2019 and that is atomic heartless
oh atomic heart oh yeah which will have
a terrible storyline I'm sure but
there's so many ideas on display I just
cannot wait to see its execution it's
been ridiculous and weird and crazy for
years nice and it's still planning on
coming in 2023 I'm excited and I'm
hoping that this is the time when it
actually shows up you know you you see
their their their influences on display
you know they're very unabashed in their
in their bioshockness uh you even see
the half-life influences there's there's
portal influences there's just they're
all right there on the screen I say it
is it is uh kojima's weird Russian
cousin that made this game
and it looks absolutely glorious story
will be completely Madness I'm sure I'm
looking forward to that so that that is
the one that I've been keeping an eye on
for for some years now good choice yeah
I love that and I've been watching and
loving that game since before it was
even announced on Xbox's stages coming
to Game Pass it blew my mind that even
because it looked from the jump that it
was going to be a AAA game that they
would put a lot of effort into so the
fact that Microsoft was able to secure
that into game password very surprising
to me so I'm very excited to see how the
execution of that is and as as I'm also
a a an indie fan I must also say I'm
excited for silk song Oh yes yes it is
it has been on the list for quite some
time uh uh as I find myself liking
things that I didn't think I would you
know the vampire survivors has taken
over my life in certain instances things
like that so you know the the smaller
team the little effort uh as as uh as
Lord Sovereign was putting it it is game
like it is it is like the quintessential
you know it is your you start from zero
to a hundred in 30 minutes and you're
always satisfied at the end it's pretty
awesome so games like that always speak
to me um I find it was a travesty that
that uh call to the lamb was not
recognized as it should because I think
that was one of those you know that was
one of those those things and I gotta
say it I'm on the boat oh I'm I'm on the
boat with y'all I am a huge huge
anticipated star field selection
[Music]
it's like Skyrim mixed with no man's sky
and both the games I really enjoy to
this day I think no man's Sky started
where it started and it is all the
Triumph of Epic Proportions you know you
play it in VR it'll change your life
that thing is amazing so yeah oh it's
it's great you know and just the game
alone and if you're telling me if you
give me a game with that much depth and
then I get out of my get out of my
spaceship and I'm in Skyrim in space Oh
yeah I'm there so so those those are you
know those will keep me occupied for a
good amount of 2023 and and then you
know the next vampire Survivor or tunic
or that's door or whatever else Pops in
there that you didn't know was was
surprising that's what I'm looking
forward to right now the choices no
doubt Lord addict the picky one
what are you looking forward to so it's
the highly anticipated games for 2023
I think uh starfa's definitely up there
um
I'm curious of how blade ends up making
that year
um I'm not really anticipating it but I
know that's like a huge game for a lot
of people
um I would say Resident Evil 4 is really
high up there with me too the the Remake
resident before it's crazy next year's
so many remakes that's your favorite
Resident Evil too so I think the next
six months is uh you know gonna be very
good a cholesterol protocol it comes out
next month but it's like the next six
months I think that's gonna I've seen a
little bit of things about it that I'm
not really like I might not be there day
one now uh because apparently it's like
really like
like a melee game apparently like
there's a lot more uh focus on melee
combat than I originally anticipated and
I don't know how I feel about that yet
I'm day one for that but yeah
but it's just it's not because I
wouldn't say this year was bad I felt
like this year was a a decent good year
for games but I do feel like
it didn't it felt like some things were
missing like it just you may be besides
god of war and out in a second you ain't
get full off of that Banger that they
just send you you already empty stomach
oh God don't do that don't do that don't
don't do the Ragnarok I I I I did beat
it though so oh oh okay and I'm playing
Vampire surviving my bad I couldn't get
over off the good addictive game to get
over to that DLC but I'ma get to that
real soon
I'm sorry Ragnarok is amazing yeah
it's an amazing same thing
regardless uh you know more of some good
steak and some good steak
but I'm one of those people if I keep
getting that steak over and over again I
just lose taste for that restaurant
so so you mean to tell me you only eat
steak twice
their experience like this oh you just
want to eat it twice that's all the
second time you're done shots you're
talking about God of War every game is
the third person over the shoulder
shooter every game they got every game
is a single player third person over the
shoulder shooter and every game is the
same exact when are you going yeah you
know they are the same they all get 90s
and above yeah because they Brainwashed
the crowds
Brainwashed the crowds they grew the
hell out of them they like yo take this
that's the best PlayStation 4 game out
King
[Music]
what is your most anticipated I'm very
curious about it hey guys y'all see that
buck up right there yeah yeah that's in
our Teespring store right now
shout out to my man
I'm winning in the lab and we came back
with this joint it's crazy it's crazy
it's hilarious hilarious
um anything Gamepad
um
so I'm not gonna sit next to start
everything so get Game Pass as a game
it's the most interesting because the
service is the most anticipated Game
Pass is the platform because everything
I want is showing up there anyway
so what you want me to say Starfield is
showing up there you want me to say uh
uh uh um what's hell blade showing up
there all these games are showing up
there anyway that's the first party so
that's a no-brainer my biggest question
is what these guys got is it gonna be a
bone dry next year hopefully Spiderman
hit them streets but how are you gonna
keep holding on to November like hold on
to November to see you in November baby
in November we gonna have a banger for
you and it's gonna take you through the
no they finish their games in three days
and they're sitting there empty like
attic lights
it's just
if Spider-Man hit next year for them my
PlayStation can turn on God bless
um it's my PlayStation every day to
watch TV so oh no I don't do that
um
here we go the output is inadequate
yeah yeah my TV looks at them like stop
that turn that guy off he's so loud too
he he allowed family member that comes
over shut up man
I only want to hear him later sometimes
so hopefully Spider-Man shows up um and
I get a chance to turn on my PlayStation
but everything that comes out for a game
pass everything everything that come on
no no one particular title yeah
everything I mean I wanted to play
Starfield I want to play everything you
know uh Game Pass is a cornucopia of
different new titles that I don't know
what's going to be fantastic right so
it's not like I have to worry about
buying these games because I would have
never bought vampire uh saviors I would
have never brought it right I would have
saw it out of them whatever and it's in
Game Pass
I hit my download download it popped up
let me jump inside and see if it's whack
uninstall it better quickly it's nothing
that I have to you know worry about so
and if it's dope then it's dope so
there's a lot of games in it I still got
to play pentament I still got to play
all these games so my game pass is
really rocking right yeah
no doubt we got the buck up on them
right now put the link in there make
sure you go get that don't You Buck up
on them right remember send pictures
yeah for me it's pretty simple
um
Starfield man oh that's that's speaking
to me like that that's I've been waiting
for a long time you talking sci-fi you
talking a little you know Elder Scrolls
you're talking maybe a little bit of No
Man's Sky you talk about a little bit of
Mass Effect with a crew you know what
I'm saying you're talking spaceship
you're talking the great Frontier the
factions you know God tier dialogue
choices and choice very ambitious title
and I like to see but that's the outside
doing something other than Elder Scrolls
and Fallout to see what that looks like
and next gen only kind of excites me
give them the time they need I will be
interested to see when it when it
releases it's because being a kid have a
big debate on that he's like he's not
feeling it if it doesn't come in those
uh what is it the first 12 months
yeah Jordan better get out here before
June there's gonna be a problem
King wants to see that bill he wants to
show them show he wants to build them
from this time to this time this is what
we can look forward to
I listen to everything you say without
question you show up show up show up
okay and if that is the case then to me
that would leave the holiday open
and if the holidays open that's why I go
attic side what what's up well Hellboy
where where you at where you asking the
one who who whispering in the corner are
you ready are you ready yet we'll see
you know I'm saying I'll be a monster
here if they could pull out I don't know
if it's happening let's see what happens
there low keto up
if the D if the game pass deal gets done
I mean the Activision Blizzard can't
gets done fine but low-key even if it
Diablo 4 I'm a Diablo guys the other
phone look fire to me where is that at
if the deal goes through it'll be a game
fast they ain't putting that game out
without that deal going through we'll
see yeah they say sit on it that game
done good
rod is on the phone you know what I'm
saying right okay so we see what's going
on there and then the other thing I
don't know for 2023 game but the fact
they just announced it gotta see where
my Tekken is at what's going on with
that technique because
nothing about no gay man it's a multi
flat so far it's coming to Xbox though
so yeah attacking I got to see what's
going on and my little inner Corner
ksanti Indie tight joint is I'm a huge
um sweetening fan so the creator of um
squeaking and that makes iron and
Chronicle that the 108 Stars I grew up
with that for the PlayStation that's my
that's my joint so he's the he's the
baking the spiritual success to it I've
been following it that that's in-game
pass actually and uh huge you remember
soaking in uh okay remember yeah 108
Stars one to two yeah I didn't cry so
those those are mine right there but
that's what I got let's get these super
chats and move on unless anybody got
anything else
um regulator nine five one five dollar
Super Chat apparently PlayStation fan
boys don't care about the depths knowing
that they don't want the Activision devs
to work in better conditions so do they
care okay all right no they don't ever
born Saga five dollar Super Chat what's
that 10-year deal Sony might have car
longer than they have bungee hashtag
book of X okay oh everybody you know
it's funny because of bungies like past
and he's not really 100 right there
yeah once they start going down they
might leave
well we know the budget oh yeah buddy
we'll be out
uh Bungie got the VIP Escape ship that's
on the side you know the one that they
should have had on the Titanic and that
they got that whole thing to themselves
they just they go on there one person 40
minutes leave they always got a
contingency plan let's just say like
budgie is The King and I will say this I
don't want to feed it too much attic and
Lucas we definitely fan but the word on
the street is since a certain
acquisition the quality I don't know if
y'all buying into that's too early to
find
because people coming at me like what's
up I thought you said the bag was
dropped and how come there's bugs all
over the place and again I'm like I
don't know what's going on I think
people are just fatigued with the
seasonal content model it's kind of like
new season new yes activity with
variations there it's either three
player four player
a six player I don't know about the four
player it's either three player or six
player activities you know and people
are just getting sick of like doing that
and I think
um
oh dear I don't even remember the last
time I finished a season pass
naturally for Destiny 2. I actually took
a break and
um I went and I played other games this
year yeah if you are will you play other
games you know you know it's been pretty
productive I I think like 15 games this
year so in comparison to like the nun in
the last few years
no nothing yeah sick and tired of doing
the same thing over and over again right
you moved on right yeah so it's just I
think people are just tired of the
seasonal motto but I do think that a lot
of people are going to come back for
lightfall because I'll be back for
lightfall and I'll be okay you're
waiting for that what it is I think all
three of y'all are at this point addict
Luca you know King I think y'all
expansion people you need the big meaty
content huge stuff to do true
transitional stuff as opposed to the
seasonal bottle maybe that's just
wearing no my thing is I get on every
day in this college I feel like you
gotta do your homework
[Music]
over and over again and then there's no
guarantee in this Mission
you're gonna get this no it's it's uh
you know luck of the draw and now um
listen I got other stuff to play like
Lucas said I feel that last time we
played was probably together oh yeah
I mean that wasn't me though like I I
used to just play Destiny like I would
play the the Rinky Dink uh expansions
you know what I'm saying I would get
through all of them I'd get to 100 plus
you know but it's just it's just fatigue
I'm just tired I'm just tired
it's just like when it comes to me and
Destiny I I I'm excited for this new
expansion because it's gonna actually
introduce a new area I just tired of
finding the same people
I want new ads get them ads up I'm doing
the same trolls
don't do that
you're busy love betray too awesome
Zelda Street Fighter 6 silk song for him
that's his 2023s how did she Fighters oh
yeah yeah Zelda I get a chance to turn
my switch on hello
hello here we go and then we got frames
per second we outside though sir X-Men
two not Super Chat the one thing that
makes star feel perfect is Co-op
um something different that's different
they do that over here
call we find out a Super Chat they all
do follow the same template God of War
clamp climbing and animations look just
like Horizon forbidden West they make
good games but they really need some
variety they need to put co-op in it
couldn't it be great if somebody could
be a trace and not just watch you
wouldn't it be fantastic if somebody can
control something in the Horizon
wouldn't it be fantastic if they weren't
held back by the last uh generation
wouldn't it be great if they was
actually great wouldn't it be great if
you washed your eyes and realize
it's been over a long time ago I do I do
I'm not agreeing with King on the camera
I'm definitely not there but I do feel
like
God of War showed because I've seen is
as good as God of War was right Rock was
an amazing game I am seeing the fatigue
a little bit on that Sony template uh so
you know I think they can get away with
it for a couple games but I do see it
you know some people are starting to you
know say you know we we don't want
drastic change we do want you to change
it up a little bit because there was
someone that made a video that was
comparing all the past like five years
of of Sony games and it's like they all
had like a person that they tag along
with you and then anybody says
what did she call she said that help or
something like that yeah I said she
should I said idea that I said since you
show you what that the street you what
this level is small you sure she's like
I'm poor I was like I'm gonna tell you
how I feel I said all right I respect
you I was just trying to save you to
save your timeline for what the [ __ ]
that I don't say for timeline It's
Entertainment that's good I got to see
salute uh Eric because you know I
haven't talked to her in a minute too no
doubt Shout Out To The Man Without Fear
I've been for 10 months great show this
week lord it's always good to see my man
K asati on the panel King feel better
soon brother
no doubt no doubt thank you so much I
think we are caught up don't miss one um
oh man we're solving's here to say
because he said 40. Mandingo mcdickins
ten dollar Super Chat to be clear Sony
is aware that they will be a there will
be a number of people that will lose
their job if this deal doesn't happen
what makes Sony believe that Activision
will deal with them if the deal is next
oh that's exactly what I'm dealing with
them but they don't care okay they're
still gonna
if the deal doesn't go through they
sound like they're gonna pull it off of
PlayStation like they're still gonna
sell it on Playstation I'm just curious
if they'll be willing to work with them
on exclusivities and stuff because it's
like like especially like the people
making the decisions it's like yo you
cost me right a huge paycheck and a
human element of people in those bad
conditions right that we're hoping
because of those scandals and everything
that's going on in them you know in the
building
yeah so there's a human element to this
and I do agree it sounds like yeah okay
it sounds like like basically basically
what what the the by the nature of the
way they're handling the relationship in
the situation Sony is inadvertently
making turning Activision Blizzard into
square but for Xbox you know what I'm
saying we'll talk with them the bag is
the bag but you know the blood may be a
little bad at this point
exclusives what's the deal don't go
through right okay and
the deal comes up with them for Call of
Duty
and they said no we're just gonna give
it to Microsoft
no I don't think that no we're just
gonna give it to them we just don't go
over there they're gonna drop the bag
and you're not gonna get it remember
that stuff that you said remember what
you said like God Bless
but we was doing good God bless get up
out of my office B God
blessed they was gonna put on Nintendo
anyway they sell better
it'd be funny if they get like scenarios
where like timed exclusive content and
stuff uh or just full-blown exclusive
content for Xbox when it comes to like
the days DLC and stuff with that and
then uh Sony hears about it when it goes
on Twitter like when it actually
announced and they call them like what
happens like what happened to that money
I was supposed to get
messy messy messy look let's see what
happens that's awesome chat final time
this will be quick we'll get everyone
out here and um yeah this is me team
ninja
um responds looks like there was a post
initially you know in reference to I
guess the G econ I can't pronounce it
igc this uh that weekend where teams
ninjas um I can't pronounce his name
fumahiko hey you shoot it you see that
held a presentation he had a slideshow
suggesting reboots of Ninja Gaiden and
dad are a live class so they were slide
shows literally of this and then um
there was a follow-up statement because
everybody's like yo did you get in you
know Dead or Alive potentially coming
back now the creative director Tom Lee
said that despite showing both franchise
at this conference uh under the under
the heading of rebooting popular series
The Studio has nothing to announce
regarding new entries they're alive and
Ninja Gaiden are both long-standing
pillar franchises for team ninja these
celebrated titles are synonymous with
our studio history and reputation it
goes without saying without speaking
about the development of our past future
projects both of these important titles
cannot be left without mention however
there are no details or information to
share with either of these franchise at
the present time so it's a current
little um frenzy going on I'm just going
to speak because this is what is my
topic
um it's interesting because obviously
these two are very near and dear to me
you know saying Ninja Gaiden you know
with the original Xbox you know kind of
Dark Souls like like my kind of first
introduction to like really difficult
game content stylish all that and then
the data live connection is big fight
game fan you know and remember Ryu
Hayabusa was in you know what you call
Dead Alive and and they had some story
crossed over and stuff like that can you
remember the counter system what is it
like the paper scissors rock punch down
or whatever that kind of they grab and
we gotta admit that'll rely for its time
was one of the best looking games
remember the stage you kicked people off
you had the stages that multiple level
stages that was the first one that did
Broken um
break through the stage go through the
wall go to a whole never level of the
stage that kind of thing and let's be
real king a lot of a lot of young men
their motherhood was was groomed through
the uh the curvature and the uh bouncing
physics certain things
the female characters yes yes it was a
highlighted yes yes and if you got the
Japanese version Oh Boy reduce the the
the situation yes yes I will always
purchase the chat
yeah there's clearly clearly on the
bucket list but um somebody's out to as
we see do three DOA three turn heads
pause yo stop it relax yourself relax
yourself gentlemen but um yes I just
want to talk about it so obviously they
made the statement not the announcers
time but oh y'all buying this
but I'm not I'm not getting that I've
not played I've not played any of the
games in that franchisor Series so uh
but yeah thank you so much for having me
I do
I do appreciate you having me on
um you know I'm fine as you can see
finally on camera you guys can see me
now why are you holding back all this
great that's what I'm talking about
that's not she don't want the stalkers I
get that I get it oh God now her Twitter
about the ex she about to be late super
let down but tell the people before you
go tell the people where they can find
you with the scum yeah you guys can find
me on Twitter at the ash I also have a a
channel where I hold a podcast every
Saturday at 6 PM Central Time 7 Eastern
caught scum cast covered gaming in the
first half and then we'll cover other
topics like so when you're gonna have me
back home the last time I was you're
welcome anytime
I was there how many times oh okay no
problem
everyone is welcome anytime you just
gotta hit me up no doubt for that in the
chat go check her out the lady Luca the
acid one so loose is always good to talk
he's been a minute I was like you know I
talked to Luke in a minute let's get her
in the round Salud says enjoy your day
you already know just don't relax with
that Chicago pizza because you know you
get okay I listen I don't need to hear
this thunder before
all right okay bye guys
salute to the Luca no doubts get this
final topic so Kate it's on you man with
uh Ninja Gaiden and DOA D are you buying
it oh the whole back and forth about
this nothing to report that stuff just
just throw that that stuff away we're
excited let us be excited even if you
ain't got nothing to to to necessarily
announce right now that is a that that
those two are franchises that like it is
like and I'm I'm on my Square let's go
much much like Jet Set Radio and Jet Set
future
it has been far too long since since we
saw these two franchises come back I too
like I worship at the altar of Team
ninja when it comes when it came to that
time uh yes I know that the from soft
way has has taken over the nation but I
am one that says that team ninja was
there before
right like they they were doing what
they were doing before it was popular
and and no no disrespect to the from
software it's just amazing where they're
going but I love to see Team ninja like
rethink the original and bring them back
yes and you know like you were saying
the the for its time the graphical
output that was it was doing you know
you you there were no aliasing for some
reason even though you're on OG Xbox it
was very very crisp and cool you know it
still holds up today as a dude who likes
to emulate my stuff today it is very
cool so so I'm happy to hear that that
you know even they're even thinking
about you know these franchises yeah you
could you can say the whole you know
nothing to report here but to try and
kibosh the whole thing come on now we're
excited let us be excited I think it's
great so I completely agree I got a
great protocol shout out to Mandingo Vic
Dickens Final Super Chat I remember when
my mother walked in with me while
playing dead or alive she saw the
voluptuous
Ayanna in revealing clothing she took my
controller and we prayed
I hope I hope that was just during DOA
and not the tennis not the the
volleyball version
I had that too your mama would have
asked you to you know we need to go see
Jesus
none of that could Grace the streets
bro
so what you guys be talking you locked
your door before you played better
basically it was real out there in the
streets like I said boys the caveman
[Music]
man I don't know if
actually I don't know what are you
talking about either yes I'm curious
about your your connection to either or
if not any dead or alive on this guy uh
I don't care about that or alive uh but
you know Ninja Gaiden I was like I would
actually like it if there's not movement
on that brand I feel like Microsoft
should move on that brand because they I
think they they need look does all from
software games get exclusive to Sony no
but there's there's enough where it's
annoying and and I feel like they need
their own you know demon so maker they
need
a bloodborne maker and I feel like you
know the game that's about to come out
was made by team ninja isn't it
on coming yeah we're on great game and
that's it I actually
play in that game
it's not a from software game but I
think it's from what I've played of
their games it's the one that resembles
more like from software games than
anything else absolutely I think that's
kind of one of the OG Origins you
actually said something that me and
Maddie had it so Maddie agrees with you
we got a little little debate on
defining joking he said he agrees with
you he feels that
Microsoft is synonymous with Ninja
Gaiden and that he feels they need to
make that exclusive so I was like well
what about the Game Pass back or he's
like nah it's like Kotor I should think
about that with Xbox he said Microsoft
need to make that happen what do you
feel about that you agree you think like
they need to drop an exclusive bag even
the Game Pass wouldn't be enough and now
it's got to be exclusive yeah I was a
little disappointed with them that well
well uh woolong is not exclusive like
sure the Game Pass bag is gonna do is
gonna really help the the subscription
service but I feel like that exclusivity
would help the brand okay and uh you
know
they're doing better when it comes to
stuff like that
um I am skeptical if they would ever
back the truck up to make something
exclusive when it's probably cheaper
just to make it a Game Pass
exclusivity so but you know there's some
decisions you got to make that doesn't
make sense because of your subscription
service but it's better for your brand
in the long term and I think having
their own type of those type of games
makes better sense like brand wise than
it does you know game pass-wise I will
say this
if the deal get black
these are the type of things that could
happen
these are detectors you gotta gotta pay
attention to moving forward Lord King
for spring slanderous thoughts what are
your feelings man we grew up with these
gays bro
well I don't feel it should be exclusive
at all oh okay okay put on Game Pass
Game Pass is the model it's not the
platform it's not the console Game Pass
is the the platform Game Pass is the
model don't don't go over there giving
them no extra money you ain't gotta give
them put them on Game Pass then this
time slot slide up in here and um use
anonymous because when we Market Game
Pass and I said we because I play it all
day or what and you're going to see it
over there and you're gonna be like
you're gonna have to make a pimp
decision okay you I want to go pay 70
dollars
and some of y'all doing the digital and
I'm gonna tell you be afraid of their
digital situation
you don't own that other side of the
fence yeah and um
oh you're gonna go get it uh physical
whatever you're gonna do
I'm gonna go get in the game pass
so drop the bag and Game Pass do that
with the DOA too I don't care at all
because at the end of the day
I'm not running out spending all this
extra dough on games for no reason I'm
gonna download because in my heart
I'm not getting rid of Game Pass
so anybody sitting there talking about
oh nah you know I don't know about game
pass because no cause you're afraid to
financially you won't be able to keep up
with that fish oh I don't do that don't
do that that's exactly don't do the
credit card slander so check it out I
like to own
what's stopping you from owning Game
Pass
are you implying okay that dude's
credits are the situation to be
comfortable to maintain Game Pass I
talked to this dude the other day let's
go and I said something about Game Pass
yeah
he said oh word what's that I said it's
on your Xbox he said oh yeah I tried to
do that but it needed a credit card
come on okay
he said he needed a credit card and I
said okay well what you can do is you
can go out and you can buy because he
didn't know there was other options you
can buy these cards right and then you
can add game pass on that way so he was
like yo thank you for letting me know
because sometimes everybody's situation
ain't your situation but it needs to
know different Avenues in order to get
things right right right so like some
dudes don't have the 400 to go out and
get a console right what they do is they
go get that
um that console thing that you pay over
a period of time that you get Game Pass
or Xbox all access right all access
joint so there's different ways for you
to get inside the ecosystem me
personally these two games is a perfect
fit for Microsoft you know ninja guy is
definitely a perfect fit for myself oh
yeah I don't think that this current
regime
views exclusives and the data has come
out that exclusives don't sell consoles
you know it just doesn't y'all get
you're selling to the same team you're
selling to the same people that was
sitting there waiting so that's why you
know Jim can say stuff like you're not
enough because it's not bridging a gap
to get to something else and especially
when you say something like let's say
Let's Take God of War yeah because you
guys gonna do it
um
so let's say that a dude went out and he
goes and he buys God of War one and then
he gets God of War Two so you know you
got to finish that and you gotta finish
this now let's say it's a dude oh girl
that purchased God of War 2 because they
played one right
some people very rarely waited this long
and I saw a couple of people waited this
round to get this game for this console
but that's very few and very far between
so you have to you know diversify it so
again exclusives don't sell consoles
yeah that's nice for talking points for
Fanboys like myself
but at the end of the day
I don't care it's a game pass I had to
push back a little bit on that
exclusives might not sell consoles to
the degree but they do give a console an
identity and I and sometimes an identity
is just as important when it comes to
branding like when you see something
like God of War you see Kratos you know
that's not on anywhere else like just
what's the identity now that the CEOs
are at
yo come on what's that branding now and
he on the Mount Rushmore
[Laughter]
that brand is snitching hold on hold on
there is there is something to that
point that y'all are making right now I
know it's all fun and games but if we
live in a world where the where the the
deal is blocked you're basically
effectively telling Microsoft that the
way that they've been doing business is
not as as not as optimal or as
appreciated as the way Sony does
business yeah you know effectively tell
him to act like to act like Sony but at
that point they got a bunch of money in
their pocket and you're telling them
that their kumbayaways ain't working you
might start seeing some money hat right
yeah because that's what they've been
doing all this time and the market
Leader's way is the way you're saying
that they the way should be by the very
nature of blocking them from doing it
the other way
it should be interesting it it is
interesting I mean both of y'all make
good points it's I I get it you know
look I'm not gonna be mad if it was
exclusive no you know what I'm saying
but at the end of the day I I do Colleen
with King in the sense that I do think
it's just not the model for them at this
time they just you know just just think
about the pushback they got where they
tried that what was it rise of the Tomb
Raider yeah and people like oh this is
not synonymous with your brand and you
know what I'm saying and why are you
doing it oh shout out to Matt Matt
having as gifting five IOP memberships
with the Cresta thank you that's love
absolutely appreciate it yeah I
appreciate that
um yeah so it's just like you know I
just think there's a different place and
they looking at driving you know game
pass but yeah I care about these
franchises a lot I want to see what
happens with them team I love that team
ninjas outside they're thinking about
bringing them back I'm with UK it's like
hey once you put that on an internal
slideshow for like you doing it it's
just you're not ready to talk about it
at this time that's all that is you you
doing it though you do it so that that
makes me smile and I'm team fighting
game I'm sorry so I said I think that
that does make sense to a point and
they've been working on Game Pass for a
while but I feel like if they were
completely against exclusivity and just
Game Pass yeah they would have put
Starfield on both platforms
um I do think that they are still in the
the the business of making exclusive
titles it just got to make sense to them
yeah and uh that's why you know when it
comes to you know I personally feel like
team ninja is like top five people they
need to buy because I feel like team
ninja serves the type of games that they
don't have at all
uh but you know it it is what I want to
see I do feel like what happens with
this Activision deal is going to
determine a lot of things
and it's interesting I think they're all
about exclusives when they own it when
they own you they own the building then
you are you mine that's it but if I own
you yeah whatever you want to be yeah
you get over this game I'm not talking
about a full-blown exclusive but even a
timed exclusive
like but isn't that a Time exclusive
sometimes when games go to Game Pass
like some of those games is over there
first for a period of time well no see
that's a different scenario like if like
Persona 5 for instance like I'm not
waiting
you don't care if it comes to Gamepad
they could literally say Persona 6 is
coming to Game Pass in Xbox six months
after PlayStation and I'm still buying
at PlayStation 5. it's just like that's
one thing they can't do they can't miss
on these games facts it don't matter if
it's not on Game Pass or that at least
gotta be on the platform facts I'm with
you all the way on that one out of like
they and I think they're doing a better
job of that like they're still little
ones here and there that Miss but for
the most part it seems like they're
getting the major ones so that's dope
but uh yeah that's what I got y'all
that's all I got I think the super
chance caught up just let me know and if
I didn't miss anything I get the um the
pole which I should like all right if
the potential Microsoft acquisition of
Activision Blizzard King is blocked by
Regulators which concession do you think
Xbox should make in hopes of getting the
deal approved the choices are a Call of
Duty removed from Game Pass
B Call of Duty parody with PlayStation
Plus
C Call of Duty remain on Playstation
like Minecraft or D I don't care I'm
blocking everything to protect my
PlayStation
shout out to the legendary the valari
gaming fellow brothers the D that came
through link is at the top is a post at
the top of the chat and again we got a
promotion going with our partnership
with those uh amazing gentlemen and
again if you want one of the best
Comforts in gaming you see it right
there that is the Volari right there
support if you're hardcore gaming I'm
telling y'all right now playing extended
hours on these games elbows your joints
it is the most comfortable thing I have
ever seen and enjoyed I can't play my
games without it VR console You Name It
We Do It Mobile check that out the link
is in the description I'll put it in
there again use code Lord 15 if you want
that 15 off are exclusive for the
pre-order page so check that out right
there by putting it in there again for
y'all and I was like I don't want you
guys to know like
I actually believe in that pillow
addict's just like you know he don't
like nothing yeah I'm very I've always
been taught I'm a very hard person when
it comes to stuff uh but I do enjoy that
that like what's funny is like I took it
to my girlfriend's house that's why I
don't have it because I left it there on
accident like because it it does make
sleeping a lot easier for me yes
absolutely go check that out support the
Lords got more things doing if you guys
hit some targets we got some fun things
for cooking so go get that Volari man go
check that out again salute to the sis
lady Luca we already see her pull up and
of course my man K Asante the homie
telephone people where they can find you
what you got going on Sir oh well first
and foremost I have to once again thank
you guys so much for having me on it's
always a pleasure being on with you guys
I as you know I am an avid watcher even
when I'm in the motherland I gotta catch
my episode I sent y'all a little video
of my my dog my daughter she did
you're not playing it you're not playing
it today I'm like uh yeah I had to
record her doing that but no thank you
guys so much uh of course as as you all
may know I host a a show with my man Mr
the the slanderous one the conspiracy
theory yeah we like to do it on Saturday
mornings 10 a.m Eastern standard time
today in circle podcast
the gaming Circle podcast gcp the geek
culture podcast we're broadening our
base you know we're doing the best we
can and we're back after two week Hiatus
we got to get you to a thousand yeah
y'all got to get over there we're close
get these boys to a thousand Subs right
now we're doing the March we're doing
the March you know we appreciate all the
the support we have been getting so
thank you guys so much you know we we
see a lot of great great community
members also in your chat that join ours
and we appreciate the continued support
and you know come join us Saturday
mornings we get a little slanderous we
keep it PG-13 so you can you can listen
to it with the kids but yes we we do our
best we enjoy it we enjoy it appreciate
you but thank you for holding us down
man really appreciate it it was always
good to get always good to get your
Insight and of course the case just
landed but you're good today you were
good we keep we keep a PG
my bro okay appreciate you brother we
got to get everybody here because I
don't know how you keep that man in
check that man oh you know you know I
love you so tell us the dynamic duo
sometimes I'm not sure which ones will
and which ones yes yes they'll play off
each other Goods know that I need to do
something
um I want to see y'all do some stuff
with DPS so y'all been working with DPS
yeah we want to do a little crossover yo
that's the perfect
you already know Lord at it again
appreciate you coming through I know you
were really sick wasn't feeling well I
wasn't sure you was gonna be able to
make it but it was good to see you where
can the fine people find you what you
got going on
finally going back to sleep see you guys
next time hey there you have it
okay but anyway my man so there we go
Lord saw again he had to dip out but he
was here earlier send him some love even
though Kingdom like when I say that and
Lord King glad you can make I know you
are not feeling well I called you bro
I'm surprised you was able to rock the
whole thing appreciate I'm not gonna do
that I got no choice I love you bro like
I love both of y'all cause y'all it's
hard to do a show so y'all here y'all
give me energy I'll be hyped that's why
um I know addict gives me so much energy
he don't know that's when I started
getting Lively
um first I want to give a shout out to
valari you guys heard go to their site
yes pick up two pillows and you get 20
off can't pick up two pillows pick up
one pillow put iron what is it iron Lord
15. yeah Lord 15. but Lord 15 on the
checkout yeah and then you get um
exclusive ILP jump right there right
there shout out to Lady Luca fantastic
stuff go to her uh Channel stumpcast you
know go sign up over there yes okay
Asante that's my dude uh go to his uh
his podcast Circle
fantastic stuff they had a great show
yesterday they helped me while I was
dying in bed you know
trust me man I just I just left it on
that was listening laid out there
um
also go to our Teespring store and go
get that buck up
um
it's hilarious
something that you can tease people with
we had a teaser season two of the dudes
because you know they out here repping
racks oh
yeah yeah when you pick up the don't
buck up on me just make sure you pick up
to stop smoking
we doing it two for one that's how we
doing it you gotta you gotta show that
you you joking because you're not really
about that life
[Laughter]
yeah my congestion is coming in I'm out
of here guys go love you talk to you
guys later look that's all I got
everybody good great to see y'all
another Dope Show we will catch y'all
next Sunday the same bad time same bad
Channel that's all I got everybody enjoy
your Sunday
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]